Jack was swimming deep underwater
wondering why he had such a pounding
headache when suddenly he had a
terrifying realization he had no idea
where he was or what he was doing there
was a nagging feeling that he must have
a specific reason to be here you don't
just end up deep in the ocean with a
diving suit on by chance yet he had no
idea what he was supposed to be doing he
wasn't sure he cared either he was more
worried about the throbbing pain in his
head and the vision of two eyes staring
at him out of the dark that he couldn't
get out of his mind his heart began to
race as he wondered what to do and how
to get help he was in the middle of the
ocean and appeared to be all alone he
couldn't see anything in the Dark Water
except for this weird gray substance in
front of him maybe he was gonna die here
alone without knowing if anyone could
even hear him he began to speak aloud
about how he was consumed by sickness
and that Darkness was all around him
this is the story of one of the most
powerful and dangerous anomalies yet
discovered
scp-3000 before Jack's descent into
despair the SCP Foundation had mandated
an explored Expedition off the coast of
Bangladesh after receiving a few strange
reports from locals and fishermen the
foundation suspected an SCP was lurking
in the water and positioned a few
Personnel to investigate the crew
expected danger or maybe even death but
what they got instead was Far stranger
and more ominous all of the men had been
verified to be in sound mental States
when the mission set out but a few of
them reported feeling strange and uneasy
as the submarine descended into the
ocean before long a veteran agent named
Dr Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel straight range
multiple agents developed a creeping
feeling of unease that swept over them
one of the calmer men tried to reason
with Dr Williams asking him what was
wrong and if he could explain exactly
how he was feeling that's when things
got even stranger Not only was the
doctor extremely anxious but he now
seemed incapable of giving a real
response to any questions thrown at him
he could only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calmed crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every time he looked at his
colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as scp-3000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with the head as big as
a town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and life had left him and he just
began screaming no repeatedly again and
wouldn't respond to any attempts to calm
him down not that anyone else was very
capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
fell to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came afterwards the image of the
eel-like creature's eyes seemed burned
in their minds permanently it would
haunt their waking hours for the rest of
their lives and sleep was no Escape
either as they would appear in both
their dreams and nightmares alike
forever a second mission had to be sent
to gather more information about the
strange Beast already there were many
theories and question marks surrounding
scp-3000 how big was it really was it
sentient what was the liquid for none of
the men who had been on the previous
Mission were willing to return to the
waters but a new group of Brave recruits
volunteered they were about to find out
what so many in history have learned the
hard way that bravery and foolishness
are often mistaken for the same thing
this time the mission would not be in a
submarine but in dive suits in order to
observe the anomaly in even closer
detail and to eliminate the chance of
one team member self-sabotaging the
submarine killing them all they were
transported to the location by boat and
the three men splashed into the ocean
they descended and at first everything
was going well in case anything went
wrong the three of them were tethered
together for extra security but the
deeper into the ocean they swam and the
closer they got to scp-3000's location
they got the stranger things became just
like on the last mission first there
were a few minor cases of confusion one
of the team Jack thought it was his
responsibility to lead the navigation
but another Roberto also thought it was
his job in fact navigation was actually
the job of a third team member Amir but
he seemed to have forgotten everyone was
getting confused the team listening in
on the conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away two years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut tether that
was holding them together all alone Jack
couldn't remember where he was or why he
was here he desperately looked around to
try and gauge his surroundings but he
could only see Darkness all he could
think about was a pair of large eyes and
an overwhelming fear of Despair and
anxiety and this weird gray fluid that
was now floating in front of him the
foundation listened as Jack started
reciting a creepy speech about being on
the edge of nothing inches from Oblivion
with a sickness in his mind and nothing
but a pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through the radio it sounded
like a huge creature was swimming toward
the men it had to be scp-3000 but all
three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even
see what was in front of them claiming
they couldn't see anything in the
darkness there was silence for half a
minute with the team listening in
fearing the worst then they heard some
more unintelligible mutterings the men
must be alive but what on Earth was
going on then the gibberish started
again two of the men were screaming that
Jack had just been swallowed whole and
that they were being sucked in in two
why couldn't they just swim away it was
chaos but then a few moments later
Roberto spoke into the radio saying he
was floating alone in the middle of the
ocean and had now moved away from the
eyes of scp-3000 he finally seemed
capable of forming coherent thoughts in
speech after what had just happened
Roberto now had a theory he thought that
somehow it was impossible to think
straight around scp-3000 when he'd been
close enough to see the eyes Roberto had
felt a throbbing pain in his brain and
been unable to think about anything
perhaps it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of scp-3000 now and
Roberta was determined to get a sample
despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later git acquired some very important
data but he seemed to have lost all hope
of preserving his life Roberto started
telling the team over the radio that he
was dying and that his heart rate was
too high but cautioned that it would be
too dangerous for anyone to try and
rescue him the Personnel continued to
try and communicate with Roberto to
figure out what was going on but his
words had stopped making any sense until
finally he went quiet minutes turned
into hours hours into days and still
there was no sign of Roberto or the rest
of the divers after three days His Radio
which had only been sending a steady
stream of Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y-909 a chemical compound an extremely
strong anesthesia y909 causes head pain
paranoia fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams in the diving Trio the
collection of y-909 might have resulted
in two disastrous missions but there's a
silver lining as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by scp-3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not farewell in storage
or cause undesirable side effects the
only problem is the method of sourcing
the only way to obtain why 909 is
somewhat epically questionable for most
people
scp-3000 produces y909 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated d-class
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close unaware that this
mission is one way only other divers are
then sent later to collect the fluid
from a safe distance and store it of
course it's all for the greater good of
humanity now the foundation protects
scp-3000 as best as it can guard
something hundreds of kilometers long
the area is carefully patrolled and
members of the public are not allowed to
enter the part of the bay where it
resides anybody who accidentally comes
into contact is contained eventually
another pair of foundation doctors went
down in the submarine to try and learn
more about scp-3000 one became so
affected by why 909 that he began
hallucinating he started talking about
ananta shesha the king of serpents in
Hinduism anatasha is believed to be all
that will be left after the end of the
world because it exists throughout all
of time simultaneously the doctor said
he believed that this was in fact ananta
Shasha that scp-3000 simply shows us
that eventually everyone dies and Fades
into the darkness of Oblivion right
before he exited the submarine and swam
right into his mouth luckily for now
scp-3000 seems to be in a sort of
hibernation state it rarely moves and it
doesn't hunt although it will eat when
fed but no one knows when or if it'll
wake or what it's capable of if it does
will it destroy the world or simply
drive us all insane many children across
the English-speaking World grew up
hearing Mother Goose nursery rhymes
about mice running up clocks old women
living in
and one unfortunate egg by the name of
Humpty Dumpty but have you ever heard
the rhyme about the Crooked Man most of
us who heard that particular poem
remember it like this there was a
crooked man and he walked a crooked mile
he found a crooked Sixpence against a
crooked style he bought a crooked cat
which caught a crooked Mouse and they
all lived together in a little crooked
house a little bit odd but hey most
nursery rhymes are when have you ever
seen a little girl sitting on a tuffet
eating some curds and whey what even is
a tuffet honestly whatever curds and
whey let's just move on residents of the
Sleepy English Hamlet of temby and
Oxfordshire here a more menacing version
of the rhyme about the Crooked Man sung
as a song on playgrounds shared in
hushed tones when the grown-ups aren't
listening it goes like this there lived
a crooked man who made a crooked deal he
kept a crooked cane and his as catch and
crooked Krill he stole a crooked child
who cried a crooked squeal and that
crooked little man was broken on the
wheel it sounds just as inscrucible as
any other nursery rhyme but there is a
dark tone to it that seems a bit out of
place especially when you compare it to
the other somewhat cheery version This
creepy alternative to the Crooked Man
nursery rhyme seems to only be found in
the town of tembe and unfortunately for
the residents of that town there is a
deadly truth behind its words many years
ago the SCP Foundation became aware of a
mysterious pattern in this unassuming
town every 12 years over a period of
roughly 70 days something horrible would
happen to townspeople who happened to be
alone and indoors after dark when they
were discovered by a neighbor a family
member a friend or even the police they
would be unresponsive suffering from
full body paralysis or appearing to be
effectively brain dead this was not the
most unusual aspect of the phenomenon
though the victims were all grotesquely
transformed their long bones covered in
dozens of compound fractures combined
with excess cartilage and osseous tissue
their limbs would become distended
stretched and deformed into long gnarled
appendages like the limbs of an ancient
tree one of the recovered victims had a
forearm measured at over 2.4 meters long
another had to be placed in a specially
outfitted hospital bed as his spine and
legs had stretched to the point where he
was 12.5 meters tall local police and
doctors alike were left scratching their
heads what had happened to these people
clearly something horrible had been done
to them but there was no actual evidence
of a crime no one had been murdered and
there was no evidence of forced entry at
any of the victims homes there was
however one other piece to the Crooked
puzzle just before a victim was found
their place of residence would visibly
degrade and warm the structure itself
breaking in places until portions
collapsed in or became slanted roofs
would Tilt at an unsafe angle chimneys
would fold over and door frames would
twist until no ordinary person could
pass through them safely this happened
every 12 years for decades and none of
the people of tembi could do anything
about it in fact they rarely ever so
much as spoke of it terrified of
admitting the truth of their Town's
curse in so many words instead they
spoke about the phenomenon in innuendo
meaningful glances and pleased to keep
loved ones company at night and through
a simple children's rhyme one doctor
tasked with treating survivors of the
horror decided to do something as the
12-year Mark began to approach once more
he reached out to a researcher he had
known years ago a man who specialized in
The Unexplained things that modern
medicine had no answer for this man had
left medicine behind and was now working
for the SCP Foundation at the time of
contact there were approximately six
months to go until the phenomenon would
begin to strike once more the foundation
needed to act quickly in order to
collect more information and hopefully
find a way to stop the terror of tembi
once and for all with about a month to
go until the danger would reappear a
member of d-class personnel referred to
as d-209 was placed in a
foundation-owned house in town audio and
visual equipment were installed
throughout the house in order to monitor
it for any anomalous activity and to
make sure d209 remained at his post for
the first month of his stay d-209 did
not experience anything unusual he spent
his time drinking tea baking pies and
catching up on his reading he even
thanked the foundation for the
unexpected staycation unfortunately on
his 43rd day in tembi things changed as
d209 sat in bed reading a novel by the
Lamplight the camera feed in the living
room began to glitch a vertical
Distortion appeared with a jagged
pattern that began to make its way
across the room from the front door it
was as if something was coming inside
but the camera could not pick up its
image the Distortion continued through
the hallway until the camera placed
there cut out entirely d-209 suddenly
closed his book as the sound of
scratching came from the floor below he
began to slowly climb out of bed
listening for further sounds as the
entity continued to make its way through
the house toward him movement was
apparent on the video feed but there was
too much interference for any image of
the creature to be made out d209 froze
in his tracks as he heard footsteps slow
and certain coming up the stairs toward
him he ran to the window attempting to
pry it open and make an escape but it
would not budge with increasing
desperation he grabbed his bedside lamp
and threw it at the window attempting to
shatter the glass the lamp broke apart
but the window remained stubbornly
intact as he scrambled for an Escape
Route something knocked at his bedroom
door d-209 called out for toward the
door who is it who's there but there was
no response identify yourself still
whatever stood on the other side said
nothing holding the remains of the lamp
in one hand as a makeshift weapon d209
slowly reach for the doorknob and open
the door with a sudden pop every light
bulb in the vicinity burst including
Foundation provided flood lights
positioned outside of the house there
was the sound of snapping and then an
agonized Scream the camera adjusted to
the lack of light in the room allowing
for a clear image of d209 it was wailing
and holding his right arm which appeared
to be broken just above the elbow the
arm began to stiffen and elongate
indicating impossibly fast bone growth
screw this you're not taking me I'm
getting out of here alive he yelled
running down the hallway he collapsed as
another snapping sound echoed throughout
the hall my legs broken set out please
he called to someone anyone who might be
watching the feed slowly painfully he
pulled himself to his feet he lifted his
right arm to the camera showing that it
had been broken again below the elbow
pointing in the opposite direction of
the first break what are you doing
healthy he screamed it doesn't even hurt
anymore that can't be right I I don't
know what's happening to me as he
continued to yell at the cameras he
limped towards the stairs attempting to
make his way down to the first floor he
missed a step lost his balance and fell
all the way down twelve loud snaps were
heard as he went when he landed on the
ground his bones were broken in several
other places only to be immediately set
where they had broken as he screamed he
dragged himself into the living room
battling against his own body which had
become something foreign to him his arms
were growing longer now around 2 meters
long and his legs stretched out of the
camera's view presumably into the
hallway suddenly he stopped crawling his
eyes widening no
no he whimpered before suddenly being
dragged backwards out of the camera's
view due to the presence of the entity
interfering with the cameras all
visibility was lost at this point there
was however still a live audio feed the
microphones picked up an hour of
snapping and screaming until d209
eventually went quiet then all that
could be heard was a wet sucking sound
followed by a thumping meanwhile at the
hospital 27 other victims of the entity
were lying in hospital beds as d-209 met
his unfortunate fate all of the
hospitalized victims began to experience
seizures at the same time and seized for
several minutes five patients were
killed and two researchers were injured
in the chaos after the incident at the
hospital reports of a seismic event at
the edge of town began to circulate
because there had been no actual
earthquake in the area the research team
realized that this disturbance had to be
somehow related to the phenomenon they
planned to investigate in order to learn
more about the entity behind it all
which they had now officially designated
the scp-783 the Crooked Man a team of
personnel were sent to investigate the
site of the seismic event only to find a
group of tembi townsfolk clustered
around the area in a field at the south
of town the crowd refused to let the
researchers through and would not budge
until one researcher agent Collins
pulled out her firearm and fired a shot
into the air the sound frightened the
crowd and they realized this mysterious
Foundation really meant business where
the crowd had been agent Collins could
see toes unnaturally long crooked toes
poking up out of the ground they were
going to need some help and a lot more
shovels to uncover this Mystery by the
next day a dig Team had uncovered a mass
grave filled with victims of scp-783
there were dozens of elongated bodies
spread throughout the 5 meter wide hole
stacked on top of each other with their
heads facing down and their arms
outstretched towards the bottom of the
pit their limbs had grown around each
other twisting together to the point
where they could not be removed one at a
time while trying to collect a tissue
sample from one of the bodies researcher
singer lost his balance as the ground
beneath him gave way and he fell he
attempted to find a foothold and climb
back up but fell through the gnarled
arms and down into the pit thinking
quickly agent Collins grabbed a rope and
tied it around her waist she would lower
herself down into the grave and would
signal when she was ready for them to
pull her out agent Collins descended
into the pit over 20 meters down before
she signaled for the team to pull her
back out then she told them what she had
seen there was something down there the
entrance to another location beneath all
of the bodies someone asked if there was
any sign of research or singer Colin
shook her head face growing pale she
hadn't seen him down there he was gone
agent Collins was granted a temporary
leave of absence and a d-class
d-2172 was selected for further
exploration of the anomalous Mass grave
he was outfitted with a retractable
harness communication and video
equipment as well as a photo ionization
detector a geiger counter a basic
survival kit a firearm and ammunition
d-2172 was then lowered into the pit via
a crane after 12 meters of descent there
was no longer any visible light inside
the pit and D 2172 switched on his
headlamp a few moments later
d2172 began tugging on the tether
demanding to be lowered more quickly
when asked why he insisted someone just
touched my back at 18 meters down
d2172 began to feel a sense of confusion
and dizziness unable to tell which
direction he was going at this point in
the pit gravity he had inverted forcing
D 2172 to climb upward in order to
continue moving down as he crossed into
another world there was Daylight visible
here again as d-2172 climbed out from
within the mass of bodies there he found
a seemingly identical version of the
town of temby he was instructed to take
soil samples and the monitoring
researcher noticed something odd on the
video feed there were marks in the dirt
around the grave that appeared to have
been made by fingers pulling across the
ground they decided not to relay this to
D 2172 after the soil samples came up
normal
d-2172 was instructed to walk to a
nearby Cottage and look for any sign of
the missing researcher singer he knocked
on the door and with no answer let
himself in he saw no one inside and
began to walk through in the bedroom on
the wall there was a charcoal sketch of
a humanoid figure holding a staff of
some kind command ordered him to
approach the drawing but he protested
saying he felt incredibly uncomfortable
looking at it he relented and began to
approach but as he did the quality of
the video feed began to degrade until it
was filled with static
d2172 was then permitted to leave the
cottage and further explore this copycat
Village while walking further into the
village
d-2172 spotted a work boot on the ground
he picked it up and found it was a match
for the one researcher singer had been
wearing he followed the path to another
house the door of which was wide open he
walked inside to find signs of a
struggle an overturned couch and table a
hole in the wall the broken pieces of a
lamp scattered on the floor the kitchen
was just as much of a mess and as he
investigated it further he found a pool
of blood on the floor with significant
blood splatter on the walls and counter
it looked like someone had been attacked
with a weapon likely a knife indeed as
he looked
d-2172 spotted a Butcher's Block with
only one empty slot the one that should
have held a meat cleaver the
investigation led him to a locked door
covered in scratches he broke it down
and nearly fell down the stairs into the
darkened basement instructed to head
down into the basement
d-2172 switched on his headlamp drew his
weapon and descended into the darkness
the basement was empty except for a
bloody meat cleaver and a piece of pant
leg caught inside an exhaust vent
leading out of the house the pants
resembled those worn by singer before
his fall
d-2172 peered into the vent for a closer
look but was startled by the sight of
something scuttling out of sight
whatever it was it was fleshy and it was
not something he cared to see more of
d2172 continued on his expedition
walking North and away from the town
limits of tembi somehow in spite of this
he wound back up at the South side where
he had emerged from the pit but
something was different there were no
bodies no open grave and no tethered
harness that he had taken off when he
climbed out he was trapped the harness
had not been retracted so where had it
gone command could not determine its
exact location but proposed that d2172
had entered another anomalous area and
was not in fact back where he started he
was instructed to follow the road back
retracing his steps until he wound up at
the pit again as he walked he commented
that he had not yet seen a single living
thing in this place then as he heard the
sound of rustling leaves he turned
toward it to find the corpse of an
scp-783 victim he turned back to
continue you on his way only to see
another victim sprawled across the road
he drew his weapon then listening as the
rustling began again he spun around to
look at the body behind him and found
that it had stretched longer growing
closer to him behind him the other body
began to snap as well he turned to fire
his weapon and saw that this other body
had stretched its neck its head at eye
level only a meter away from his own
face he fired several rounds but the
corpse did not respond ignoring orders
d-2172 took off running into the woods
leaving the road behind he stopped to
catch his breath sat down and reloaded
his firearm after eating a quick MRE and
informing command of his whereabouts he
set back off on his journey through the
forest after 14 minutes of walking he
began to feel movement under the ground
short sharp bursts of motion
reverberating through the Earth he could
also hear a thumping sound coming from
beneath him on the video feed command
saw what appeared to be a silver birch
tree lifting out of sight then dropping
down back into the forest shaking the
ground on impact
d-2172 was instructed to approach the
object as command quickly realized that
this was no tree has he approached
another similar object landed near him
he fired his weapon at it and blood
began to dribble from the wound a scream
ringing out high above him not knowing
what else to do he ran as fast as he
could begging for help from command for
someone to do something to get him out
of there has d2172 ran out of the forest
making his way back to town another one
of the long pale objects knocked him
onto his back he looked up now able to
see what it was without the trees in his
way when he saw it he couldn't help but
scream it was researcher singer or at
least it had once been researcher singer
he had become something else something
Unthinkable his body was up in the sky
balancing on enormous impossibly long
fingers the creature that had once been
singer shrieked lifting a finger and
preparing to bring it down on d2172 he
fired several shots but none hit so
again he turned and ran he reached the
main road and kept running tasting bile
in the back of his throat and feeling
his lungs begin to burn he couldn't stop
if he stopped the creature would grab
him in those awful fingers and he didn't
want to think about what would happen
next then he saw it the pit the bodies
his way out he sprinted toward the pit
almost there when a screech rang out and
a massive finger knocked him aside the
video feed was lost with only the sound
of d2172 screaming and running away
after this d2172 was considered lost an
attending researcher Dr Peterson ordered
that the team pulled his harness back
out agent Collins protested saying they
had no evidence of d-2172's death
Peterson relented and they waited for
the signal eventually it came two tugs
on the tether
d-2172 asking to be pulled out but when
they pulled the tether an empty harness
emerged something was caught on it
holding it in the pit as the team tried
to draw it out it was
d-2172's hand gripping the harness as
hard as it could the harness Broke Free
from his grasp and his hand flailed
searching for his chance at Escape
another d-class rush to help grabbing a
hold of 2172's hand another d-class
joined in along with Dr Lafayette and
private Audi and the group worked
together to pull the Fallen man from the
pit on only as they pulled they realized
that only his arm had come out and it
was continuing to come more and more and
more of his arm stretching out to three
meters in length bending and snapping at
gruesome angles they were too late after
all he was already gone despondent the
group released him and he sank back down
into the pit with the rest there is
currently no way for the foundation to
remove the Crooked Man from tembi for
containment instead they must maintain a
strong presence in the town monitoring
the community via a temporary site 5.
this area includes two houses and a
building near the local hospital their
Foundation officers will track any signs
of scp-783 activity as well as continue
to research the entity's nature and any
potential weaknesses it may have in the
event that scp-783 becomes active all of
its victims must be removed from the
site of the attack their bodies must be
incinerated and they will be added to
the case file for now there is not much
anyone can do but wait and see because
the cycle isn't broken yet it's only a
matter of time the crooked man is coming
back to do his crooked Deeds be thankful
the foundation knows what everybody
needs if you want to stay yourself
protect your muscle flesh and Bone then
you'd better heed this warning don't
stay home at night alone
working at the SCP Foundation can really
get your appetite going after spending a
rough shift monitoring the acid levels
in scp-682's tank or performing the
rituals necessary to keep the Devourer
of worlds on the other side of
scp-2317 sometimes you just need a quick
snack to hold you over before you return
to the old grind problem is that the SCP
Foundation even the break room can be
perilous Dr Dan is notorious for
pilfering pudding cups from the communal
fridge and ever since the administrator
himself stole your tuna sandwich you
just don't feel safe spending your lunch
break on site anymore but this presents
its own series of issues you only have
an hour for lunch and obviously you
can't order in due to security issues
also if you're eating off site you have
even less time to finish your lunch
because the site you're currently
stationed at is relatively remote we're
talking at least a half hour round trip
to actually get to somewhere so you're
gonna need your food fast and when it
comes to fast food few eateries are as
prolific as the golden r arches
McDonald's and just to clarify this
video is not sponsored we're gonna tell
you about a horrifying anomalous secret
that this company really doesn't want
you to know about let's not think about
that just yet though your stomach is
rumbling and you need that quarter
pounder so bad that even being trapped
in the red reality with Dr Scranton
couldn't stop you from getting it when
you finally arrive you buy your typical
order a quarter pounder with french
fries a coffee and a McFlurry you see Dr
Cliff a few tables down enjoying a box
of chicken nuggets and ketchup but
decide not to engage as you sit and
enjoy your meager little lunch knowing
you'll probably be coordinating the
cleaning efforts of scp-173's
containment chamber by the end of the
day your eyes drift over to something
even more unsettling happy the current
mascot for McDonald's Happy Meals you
can't help but shudder you've seen some
pretty horrific things on the job
nightmarish things you fear no monster
but that thing it scares you those big
soulless eyes the wide gaping maw full
of two white teeth it's diabolical
sneakers no child should ever have to
look at that you can't help but wonder
whatever happened to Ronald McDonald the
hamburger happy clown that chilled fast
food to you throughout your childhood
what is he up to now well we have an
answer for you but I'll warn you you may
not be quite as eager to suck down a Big
Mac and a Diet Coke after hearing this
Ronald McDonald first introduced as the
company's mascot in 1963 had a pretty
good run before finally being largely
phased out by the company in the
mid-2010s for a greater focus on the
nasty little box homunculus you can
thank John Wayne Gacy Pennywise and
those goofballs dressed up as clowns
back in 2016 for that but like anyone
who loses favor Stateside Ronald had a
prosperous career ahead of him outside
the country well not the Ronald we know
at least you see in an undisclosed
cattle farm in 2004 most likely in North
America a monster was born a horrific
Abomination birthed from a cow like many
have theorized about scp-058 the Heart
of Darkness but this nasty little
creature wasn't a giant heart with a
stinger and Scorpion legs in many ways
it appeared superficially humanoid save
for its stark white skin its thick red
lips and its full head of bright frizzy
red hair but that was only the start of
the unnerving strangeness exhibited by
this miracle child it was born with
white gloves and long clownish shoes
seemingly grafted to its feet fresh from
birth the creature was huge with a
disportionately large head and wide
disgusting pores that seemed to
perpetually leak fry oil the creature
was unresponsive to any kind of external
stimuli perhaps suggesting it was brain
dead and it remained completely dormant
most of the time while most people would
have screamed run away or call the
police the farmers at this particular
cattle Farm decided to let it ride and
see how this whole nightmarish Affair
played out that sense of curiosity and
patience would soon pay off for them
financially it didn't take long for the
creature to grow the bigger it got the
more it looked like a giant mutant
version of McDonald's iconic mascot
Ronald McDonald and this wasn't just a
coincidence either it turned out that
this monster was somehow intrinsically
linked to the McDonald's brand because
once a day the creature would
horrifically unhinge its jaw and begin
to barf out a huge quantity of
McDonald's food and we're not talking
about raw materials that are converted
into McDonald's food the creature later
dubbed
scp-5962 vomited out fully packaged
McDonald's products the owners of this
clownish monster had just hit the
lottery so to speak while the
particulars of the deal are unclear they
somehow contacted a representative of
the McDonald's corporation based in
China in exchange for presumably a large
sum of money Chinese May McDonald's
operatives covertly entered the country
and shepherded the now massive creature
over to a mcdonald's-owned warehouse in
Beijing by this point it was around four
meters tall and weighed over five tons
it was kept inside a cage and housed at
some cost but soon enough the creature
was paying for itself as we mentioned
before the creature constantly secreted
fry oil which was siphoned off for use
in preparing McDonald's food across the
country the huge quantity of packaged
food that had vomited out every day was
also shipped off to restaurants across
the country making the Chinese branch of
McDonald's incredibly financially
successful they were able to make an
almost complete profit on all of these
foods and drinks once transport costs
were subtracted of course
scp-5962 had become McDonald's China's
best kept secret but of course no secret
this Sensational could stay under wraps
forever no matter how much people in the
warehouse were paid or threatened for
their silence if your day job was
siphoning grease off of a giant mutant
clown for the perp purpose of preparing
McDonald's food across the country
there'd be no way you wouldn't speak to
somebody about it nobody knows whose
loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship but rumors began to
spread around Beijing about a huge clown
inside of a McDonald's packaging
facility that was when local field
agents of the SCP Foundation finally
took notice two agents Jonathan Zhang
and George nagasaw were dispatched to
perform an infiltration Mission along
with a team of backup Personnel they
entered the warehouse apprehending any
employees they found as they and their
reinforcements reached the northern side
of the facility they found
scp-5962 with a heavy collar around its
neck chained to the ground like King
Kong as McDonald's employees wheeled
away carts of packaged food neither of
the attending agents were fans of
McDonald's food but even then just
seeing this horrible display was enough
to make them feel nauseous the creature
was taken and contained by the SCP
Foundation who conducted a number of
tests on it they found that the the
monster had no real internal organs
saved for 27 interconnected stomachs
genetically they also found that the
creature was far more cow than human the
same could sadly not be said for the
food that
scp-5962 was vomiting out seriously if
you were already feeling a little queasy
from all this we need to warn you that
this is the part where things get really
vile let's talk about what the
McDonald's food barfed up by
scp-5962 was actually made out of as we
mentioned earlier the food exuded by the
creature was genetically human with DNA
often matching that of people who are
alive and in no way affected by this
anomalous process tests have indicated
that certain foods condiments and
beverages correspond to more specific
types of bodily tissue and liquid for
example the bacon and Fries were shown
to be cartilage and ligaments the bread
turned out to be made from hair nails
and skin the coffee was liquefied fecal
matter the chicken nuggets were made
from fingers ovaries and testes even the
water was a mix of saline and sweat and
of course the ice cream was comprised of
pus bone marrow feces and nasal mucus
depending on the flavor you get the idea
we'll stop listing off examples before
you lose your lunch but rest assured all
of the food produced by
scp-5962 was made of human organic
matter when the SCP Foundation
interviewed Mr Chen the manager of the
facility where
scp-5962 was being held before zemnistic
treatment he seemed incredibly casual
about the whole thing as far as he was
concerned the food still tasted exactly
the same as regular McDonald's food and
it didn't appear to have any adverse
health effects beyond what you could
expect from regular non-anomalous fast
food it's actually less cruel and
disturbing than the slaughterhouses
where the meat is typically obtained Mr
Chen also contested that scp-5962 wasn't
all that dangerous either the only time
it ever performed at offensive action
was when an employee of the enemy fast
food franchise Burger King entered its
vicinity the creature vomited a stream
of hot coffee at the corporate
interloper like a fire hose until he
left suggesting that it does have some
kind of strange inherent loyalty to the
McDonald's company but still other than
this isolated incident the creature has
never even displayed sentience it was a
big strange clownish McDonald's food
dispenser when questioned about the
origins of
scp-5962 Mr Chen once again underplayed
the strangeness of the situation saying
that he'd heard rumors the farm that
sold him
scp-5962 had also sold other strange
anomalous creatures to eager buyers in
the U.S the farm which we can only
assume is situated right next to a
radioactive waste dump was also behind
scp-4158 also known as Big Charlie this
giant omnivorous and seemingly Immortal
mutant cow is believed to have been
birthed from a non-anomalous cow sold to
the Butcher's Block slaughterhouse it
looked hideous and seemed to suffer from
a wide variety of health issues leading
to the employees at the slaughter house
trying to put the creature out of its
misery however no matter how hard they
tried to kill the monster it just
wouldn't die its bones were pretty much
indestructible and no matter how much of
its flesh was cut off it just kept
growing back causing no ill effects to
the creature itself eventually The
Slaughterhouse workers tried cooking and
eating the meat leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as
non-anomalous meat much like the Chinese
McDonald's and
scp-5962 the workers had just hit the
lottery with big Charlie as long as they
kept feeding the monster which ate
everything from bricks to other
non-anomalous cows it provided a pretty
much Limitless supply of meat giving
them unprecedented economic prosperity
in other words big Charlie was a literal
Cash Cow Jeff fine the slaughterhouse
director even started worshiping big
Charlie as a kind of demigod by drinking
his blood he believed that big Charlie
was a savior sent to lift them all out
of their struggle and Desperation sadly
for them the SCP Foundation sent them
right back when big Charlie escaped
their slaughterhouse and Foundation
field agents found secured and contained
it it was a sad day for the Butcher's
Block so what have we learned today
whether you're in the US of a or the
Chinese Heartland if you're chowing down
on fast food you really have no idea
where it came from I mean we kind of
knew that already but for all we know
the food you're enjoying could have just
been vomited up by a giant fat clown or
cut from the Flesh of a mutated cow just
think about that next time you're
enjoying a burger but hey let's be
honest with ourselves we'll all probably
still eat it despite the fact that it
covers the majority of our planet's
surface we know remarkably little about
the oceans well we know how to navigate
them and how to send boats from one
continent to another the surface of the
water is usually a calm safe place where
all you expect to encounter are other
humans and the occasional storm what's
below the surface is another story
scientists estimate that we've only
explored maybe five percent of the
world's oceans and what lies in them on
top of that they estimate that we've
only encountered and cataloged 10
percent of marine life that means that
95 of the ocean is unexplored and
Untouched by humans and that 90 of the
ocean species have never even been seen
by humans it makes you think just what
kind of stuff is down there it could be
anything even mundane ocean life can be
deeply strange and bizarre there are
sharks that live for over 300 years
Blind Fish that only hunt by smell
jellyfish that are reborn whenever they
die if normal ocean life is this
terrifying and explanation-defying what
kinds of anomalies could the oceans we
swim and fish in be playing host to one
such anomaly is
scp-835 but before we get started
scp-835 is an old old file it's one of
the earliest in the foundations database
in fact like many of the foundation's
earliest documents it's been heavily
redacted and expunged to the point where
large blocks of the text are missing not
to mention the fact that it's been
locked behind a Content filter but
scp-835 is unique not because it's been
expunged and redacted but because it's
had them lifted versions of the file and
its addendum that are cleared of the
redactions have been Declassified and
released by order of 05-11 to all
viewers for some reason whatever was so
secret about this file no longer applies
but before we take a look at the
Declassified documentation let's look at
the old version to get an idea of what
exactly we're dealing with here the
attached image for scp-835 is to put it
simply gross it's what appears to be
some kind of bone or muscular growth
underwater a bit like Coral but much
more organic and flesh-like in shape the
growth is mostly white and brown but
large sections are grown over with what
looks like some kind of black mold
spores it's large too almost the size of
a person's chest and seems to continue
out of frame the caption is simply still
image from recording 81. it's not even
clear if this growth whatever it is is
scp-835 or not continuing on to the file
the object class is ketter and the
special containment procedures are
lengthier than most articles and very
detailed they explained that scp-835
must constantly be monitored and check
to see if it's growing or expanding in
the event that it becomes hostile to
Foundation Personnel something known
only as suppression tactic a-a6 is to be
activated until it ceases any hostile
action the anomaly has to be contained
in the open ocean rather than move to a
water tank or such because of the highly
aggressive response of scp-835 to
confinement for any length of time so
whatever it is it's alive it's expanding
and growing and seems capable of knowing
when it's being placed into containment
and responding angrily it's not only
sentient it's intelligent and aware they
go on to say that scp-835's waste has to
be immediately collected and contained
and that it is to be fed two times every
day though what exactly is going to be
fed to it is redacted in this version of
the file it can also be moved to a new
location up to two times a year but only
if the current location can't support it
anymore and if the move has been
approved by the site directors on top of
that Personnel have to stay away from
scp-835 at least 15 feet they also need
to have safety harnesses attached to
winches on the boat if anyone so much as
touches as cp835 all the winches will
activate and rapidly yank all the divers
back to the boat from there suppression
tactic a-a6 is again instituted but
there is another line if a staff member
touches scp-835 and is captured by it
then the anomaly is to be monitored
Around the Clock until the subject has
been released very ominous containment
procedures this Predator if it is a
predator has a penchant for consuming
people that needs to be avoided at all
costs but if someone is caught it
releases them after a while the
description of the document clears some
things up
scp-835 is a massive polyps or tissue
growths that resemble Coral it's huge
and heavy though its full weight is
again redacted and the individual
pull-ups are also huge over a meter long
much longer than any known Coral species
the Central Mass is oval and has a huge
three meter long polyp on each side of
it but can't move or budge because of
its huge weight instead it uses huge
tentacles extending from the polyps to
dig into the ground and anchor it in
place against the ocean currents these
are the same tentacles that are used for
feeding and are covered in a sticky
glue-like adhesive they're not not just
long and strong either tests have
recorded them damaging stainless steel
plating and speaking of plating
scp-835 is covered in it not steel but
some kind of organic Coral that's much
harder than steel and couldn't be broken
by even Diamond drill bits all the
foundation could get were small samples
and if that wasn't bad enough the
foundation's positive that scp-835 is
growing like the containment procedure
suggested and it's growing fast up to 50
pounds in a single day if it's left
uninterrupted but it can't be stopped it
reacts to certain chemicals that make it
close up like an oyster and stop growing
for 24 hours at a time based on that the
foundation's been able to develop and
use a chemical cocktail to force it to
Halt the aforementioned suppression
tactic a-a6 however the results of
testing it have been redacted in case
the anomaly wasn't disgusting enough it
also vomits that's right every couple of
hours it expels a large mass of some
liquidy sludge material from both sides
so to speak after sample testing the
scientists realized it really is vomit
well part of it the substance is mostly
semi-digested food fecal material and
semen but also contains live samples of
biohazardous viruses bacteria and
parasites some that the foundation
haven't even encountered before as cp835
one of these bacteria
835-i5 is a big problem for containing
scp-835 but exactly why that is is
unfortunately expunged from the file as
well between the lethal witch's brew of
dangerous diseases and the diamond hard
shell that covers scp-835's internal
guts it is nearly impossible to
neutralize or even damage it even if you
do crack the shell the diseased fluid
inside would leak out and infect you
full of diseases in seconds wow that's
kind of crazy yeah so scp-835 is a
really really really nasty customer I
mean just by looks alone it's easy to
tell 835 is probably nothing to mess
with but a simple visual of the thing in
your line of sight does no justice in
showing how actually dangerous and
disgusting it really is if you try to
break it you get your immune system
overrun by a cocktail of diseases if it
doesn't manage to eat you first the
document has one addendum an
after-action report by a member of
mobile task force Zeta 9 the notorious
mole rats the mole rats are one of the
foundation's most elite teams of Special
Operation troops like all mtfs they have
a very specific specialization one thing
they do better than anyone else in the
world for Zeta 9 it's cramped spaces the
task force is highly trained in
exploring dangerous constricted areas
especially those that lie underground
from Subterranean caves to endless
staircases and basement remembrance the
mole rats are the best of the best at
getting in and getting out the mobile
task force Zeta 9 had been performing an
investigation on scp-835 albeit when it
was considerably smaller only a meager
four tons and it had informed a second
big polyp yet just like usual four
members of the mole rats were chosen to
begin the investigation equipped with
underwater isolation suits to ward off
any biological threats Lieutenant C
sergeants l and m and Corporal h a
rookie team member who was training with
them and was ordered to only observe
they took a small underwater drone with
them one that would come in very handy
at first scp-835 didn't act hostile or
aggressive towards the members of the
team in fact it even allowed members to
swim up to it and touch it without
reacting they couldn't even tell if it
was alive or not so they sent the Drone
to approach the huge polyp on the North
side while they went around to the small
entrance on the other side of the rock
corporal H was told to remain there and
make sure that the power cable to the
Drone didn't break off or snap
everything seemed calm suddenly the
drone's claw arm jerked back having
gotten stuck in something and began
thrashing around not wanting to wake the
creature Corporal H moved forward and
tried to free the claw but then he
became trapped too the other members of
the team heard him on the radio
screaming for them to come and help him
and that he'd been grabbed by some
horrible tentacle thing that was
dragging him towards the polyp that had
opened up into a mouth the incident left
lieutenancy a bit ruffled afterward
Jesus Christ I can't do this he was just
a kid it was his first mission I should
have kept my eye on him after a moment
she composes herself and begins to
explain what happened the anomaly
grabbed Corporal age having fooled the
rest of us what we thought was the
entrance to just some cave while the
polyp on the North side was the real
entrance into scp-835 the tentacles came
out of its smaller polyps grabbed
Corporal H and began dragging him in
while he thrashed around and screamed
the boat tried to pull in the winch but
from all the activity the line snapped
in two Corporal H was pulled inside as
cpa35 and eaten the lieutenant explains
that she swam over and hooked herself to
his outstretched hand when the boat
began witching her up she said just as
she assured him that they're going to be
fine and that she's not letting go her
line snapped and they were both suddenly
pulled inside she breaks for a moment
before describing the inside as like a
wet pulsing tube like how intestines
look on colonoscopies they were both
steadily being pulled in by the muscle
contractions what doctors call peristal
the way your body moves food down your
throat and through your intestines the
only reason they weren't dissolved or
crushed was because of the isolation
suits they were wearing but they still
couldn't move Corporal H had vomited in
his suit but they were both alive the
lieutenant Thinking Fast figured out
that if they were moving through its
body they would come out on the other
end in 72 hours they had air and water
in the suits but little battery and if
the heat went out they would freeze to
death she quickly killed all the lights
and Power in both of their suits to the
minimum except the helmet lights so they
could make sure that the other was still
alive the pair stayed like that for a
whole day with absolutely nothing but
the creature's digestion and their own
breathing after a while the corporal's
face was visible he looked tired and
scared she said that 13 hours in the
kids started talking and babbling she
calmed him down and they both slept for
a bit but were rudely awoken by falling
into the stomach of the creature they
both fell out into a small chain chamber
filled with liquid and barely a moment
later their suits began to melt in the
stomach acid she yelled and they both
ran for a hole in the wall
scp-835 sphincter at this point it was
very clear that they made it into the
intestine and it was worse than the
stomach I'm sure you can imagine how
horrifying it must have be to be in the
mix of this creature's fecal waste
disgusted and vomiting the Corporal and
Lieutenant picked each other up knowing
that they were making strides of this
terrible ordeal but they reached a dead
stop the creature's rectal hole was
tightly shut blocking their escape they
decided to wait knowing that it would
have to excrete eventually and after an
undetermined amount of time I mean any
time spent in something's intestines
waiting to be pooped out is too much
time the lieutenant was shot out into
the sea but without the Corporal she is
obviously angry telling the agents to do
something expunged before declaring she
needs a drink and to sleep what a
horrifying story but there are gaps
let's take a look at the uncensored
documentation for scp-835 first let's go
back to the containment procedures what
scp-835 is to be fed is explained any
kind of local fish but higher level
mammals if it goes into a rage State
including humans in fact it seems to
calm down when digesting higher mammals
maybe it's developed a taste for human
flesh in any case the feeding should
never happen without heavy supervision
next the results of Performing tests on
the samples of scp-835 the foundation
was able to get
scp-835 is no normal Coral it seems to
be made from what can only be described
as basic human biological components the
hard outer shell is super dense calcium
like your bones but hundreds of times
harder the polyps are covered with the
same kind of enamel that you'd find on
your teeth and the fleshy muscle that
the tentacles are made of is mostly
mutated tongue cells the creature seems
to have most of the biological system we
have but they've all degraded or mutated
into almost unrecognizability except the
digestive and reproductive systems which
are highly Advanced
835-i5 the bacteria unique to the
anomaly is explained it's how scp-835
reproduces when vertebrates are infected
with it they will undergo a variety of
symptoms gaining huge amounts of weight
despite always being hungry for things
that normally can't be eaten like wood
and raw meat their skin will harden and
form polyps across its surface their
biological systems will slowly stop
working and they'll become aggressive
and then they will drastically reduce an
intelligence and motion except for the
desire to enter the sea sound familiar
that's right being infected by it turns
the victim into another
scp-835 instance with no way to cure it
and just like it seems
scp-835 is still somewhat aware and in
intelligent at one point this thing was
a normal human just in case that's not
horrible enough the after Action Report
has also been thoroughly Declassified
let's take another look to see the real
full story of what happened to
Lieutenant C and Corporal H inside
scp-835 the first reveals when Corporal
H was being pulled into the polyp he was
screaming and crying begging for help oh
God it's eating me I don't want to die
command tells lieutenancy to abort the
mission but she refuses to leave one of
her Men Behind holding his hand while
hooking them together then the line
snapped and they were pulled in just as
they were escaping the stomach and right
as she hit the sphincter she realized
the walls of the stomach were lined with
human faces screaming and wailing and
begging to be killed she pulled her
weapon out and began firing into them
and she would have melted if Corporal H
hadn't pushed her through in the
intestine the Corporal began to complain
of a rancid smell she checked and
realized he had a breach in his suit but
quickly patched it but it was too late
she looked at his face and it was
growing pustules already they burst
spraying blood and he begged to be put
out of his misery but when the
lieutenant shot her gun at him all It
produced were empty clicks she had
wasted all the ammo on the crying
stomach faces suddenly tentacles burst
through the corporal's faceplate and
simultaneously pinned the lieutenant
down she managed to flip what had been
the corporal over and wrestle with what
was left of him before the sphincter
into the stomach where his body began to
melt in the acid but before it did she
saw the corporal's face smiling and said
he loved her before he died then she
felt a burst of energy and was shot
through the exit with a troubled gleam
in her eyes she stands there telling her
story to the agent she takes a second to
gain some strength and then says I
didn't make it out intact my suit was
breached and I didn't even realize until
I took it off and saw the rash on my
skin realizing she's going to die she
suddenly puts the room she's in on
lockdown and orders the debriefing agent
to evacuate everyone else aboard
immediately just before she kills the
feed she makes one request that the
foundation not try to decontaminate the
small boat just to abandon ship and
Scuttle it on top of scp-835 on top of
the Corporal that way they can be
together in some kind of sick resting
place
scp-835 is the horrible tale of things
that can go wrong at the foundation and
two people doing their best in a brutal
situation but with the modern
containment protocols and ensuring
people know what happened to the pair
the foundation can ensure no one ends up
like the lieutenant and the Corporal
again
d-181 was used to being picked as a test
subject for the various dangerous and
downright terrifying experiments and lab
work the SCP Foundation had him perform
at secure facility site-32 he'd been
working for the organization for nearly
five years and he considered every day
he was alive a blessing and you would
too if you were a d-class Personnel
while no one's too sure on the exact
methods the SCP Foundation uses to
recruit its d-class personnel there are
a few prevalent rumors most of which
you've surely heard before death row
prisoners taken into custody by the
foundation to be unwilling Lab Rats
ordinary people that Society wouldn't
miss that were kidnapped off the streets
or sometimes just volunteers though
we're not sure who in their right mind
would willingly volunteer for one of the
most degrading dangerous positions in
the entire Foundation the truth about
d-class is that every site does it
differently and the Foundation is well
aware of the controversy among its
Personnel that comes with recruiting and
using d-class Personnel X some sites
don't even have d-class citing their use
as inhumane but at site 32 things were
ordinary and d181 was one of the many
d-class personnel drafted into the
foundation via the United States prison
system day in and day out d-181 would
have to perform tests and experiments
most of which he knew next to nothing
about thankfully for him d-181 had two
benefits that made his stay at sine 32 a
little easier first there was the fact
that site-32 was a low priority facility
it was located far away from any major
population centers and overall lacked
the expensive funding some of the larger
sites had the anomalies contained there
were still pretty dangerous but due to
the lack of available funding most of
what the foundation was able to afford
at site 32 was regulated to safe and
euclid-class objects now as we all know
object class has nothing to do with
danger levels and instead is based on
the difficulty the foundation has
containing a certain object more than
anything else so when a site such as
site32 is underfunded due to being less
of a priority to the larger organization
they're typically only going to be
containing the bare minimum in terms of
expenses that means less expensive
containment and less elaborate objects
for d181 to work with it wasn't a
guarantee of safety as nothing ever is
in the SCP Foundation but it was at
least beneficial to have an
understanding of what's going on in the
various experiments d181 had to perform
throughout the day the second thing d181
appreciated about site 32 was a little
less conventional the entire facility
was staffed by women with the exception
of male Personnel being used for testing
purposes the reason for this is due to a
very specific detail about today's
anomaly which we'll get back to but it
was something that d181 never took for
granted of course d181 was an absolute
buffoon when it came to dating and
relations between testing subjects and
researchers were discouraged and in some
cases forbidden however he never gave up
hopes that he might be able to Now find
a girlfriend while living in a building
that was less than one percent male in
population it is important that we state
that d181 was always respectful to women
and never stepped out of line which as
far as d-classes go makes him top-tier
boyfriend material maybe there's hope
for him someday so long as he survives
the deadly Daily Grind of being on the
lowest rung of the foundation while
these two things kept d181 as happy as
someone could be while essentially being
enslaved to the foundation there was a
lot to be unhappy about in his position
first there was the General danger that
came with testing with anomalies every
day where anything and everything could
go wrong and your safety was never
guaranteed then there were the dreams
most of the time d181's waking State
felt like a dream so that meant the
images his brain showed him at night
were extra weird the horrors and
Oddities the d-181 witnessed during the
day always came back to haunt him at
night whether it was a stack of talking
bowling balls attacking him in the
grocery store or a teacup that made his
skin invert itself every time he drank
it the SCP object's d181 worked with
always cropped up in his dreams at night
and they always seemed to be worse d181
asked the other d-class Personnel
stationed at the site if they had
strange dreams too and most of them
agreed that they experienced them as
well apparently working for the
foundation fired up the imagination in
an extra special way that seeped into
nighttime when d-181 would ideally be
receiving some well-deserved sleep from
the strangeness of the day but one dream
was bothering d18 won significantly more
than usual it was a recurring one
happening again and again every few
nights the same series of events playing
out over and over again the strangest
part about it was that it didn't feel
like a dream at all d181 would be laying
in his bunk inside site 32's d-class
Barracks desperately trying to fall
asleep eventually he would but he
wouldn't realize it d181 would feel like
he was asleep but he could still see the
barracks around him except he couldn't
move at all d181 was experiencing a form
of sleep paralysis a phenomenon during
falling asleep or Waking Up where a
person is unable to move or speak
hallucinations during sleep paralysis
are common but the whole experience
typically only lasts a few minutes for
d181 it lasted a lot longer and he was
aware the entire time so d181 would be
laying down in his bunk trying to fall
asleep when he would suddenly become
unable to move then from across the room
he'd see the door to the barracks open
d-181 knew that the barracks were only
accessible to the upper ranking
personnel and they never came around
first d-181 saw a large cylinder move
itself slightly into the room then the
figure it was attached to waddled its
way through the door a giant fabric doll
so big that it could barely fit itself
into the door if d181 could scream he
would he recognized the figure as an
instance of
scp-2386 one of the anomalies he was
working on the doll walks slow and heavy
trying to not collapse over its own
weight it was made of pink fabric with
its face stitched together with thread
forming a Sly smile and two buttons for
eyes it was terrifying what was even
worse were the two pairs of wings on the
doll's
like the kinds you'd see on a butterfly
or a moth the brilliant patterns look
like they were made of cloth sewn to a
pair of ordinary insect wings and
completing the doll's Patchwork
appearance the insect doll combination
stumbled towards d-181 moving across the
barracks slowly and nearly falling over
several times the creeping Terror of the
doll's slow Advance only made d181 try
to move more but he couldn't he was
completely paralyzed and subject to
whatever the doll was about to do to him
eventually the doll made it close to
d181's Bunk standing over the bed and
staring at d-181 with its lifeless
button-eyed face it just stood there
staring d181 was sweating with tears in
his eyes he tried to scream again but
nothing came out and then to make
matters worse the barracks door opened
again and what made its way through
shook d-181 to his very core it was
another doll even bigger than the other
one and behind it was another doll and
then another four dolls in total made
their way into the room and stumbled
over to d181's bed they continued to
stare crowding around the sleeping
d-class like he was a television set and
their favorite show was about to begin
Just one d-181 thought it couldn't get
any worse the dolls extended their
stubby felted hands over his face all
four of them moving in unison and then
they stopped and d-181 heard their
voices well not their voices exactly but
voices nonetheless high-pitched barely
human childish voices started whispering
to him they weren't coming from the
dolls but they could talk d-181 was
positive this is what they'd sound like
it is
[Applause]
all of these seemingly innocuous phrases
were things said to d181 while he was
surrounded by the giant dolls on paper
they sound encouraging but the context
of the situation and the way they were
said made them anything but and this
would continue for what seemed like ours
with the dolls crowding d-181 and
speaking to him in his paralyzed State
shouting the most deceptively kind
things possible over and over again all
while d-181 was aware the entire time
but before he would wake from this awful
dream one of the instances would lift
their stubby hand forward directly
hovering over d-181's arm and the doll's
appendage would caress him squeezing and
playing with his arm like it were a toy
by morning when d-181 awoke from his
dream he felt like he was never asleep
in the first place and that he could
remember every agonizing second of the
past night's experience this would
continue almost every other night as
soon as d-181 would fall asleep the doll
dream would occur again as soon as he
woke up he feel like he got next to No
Sleep the night before it was draining
him and inhibiting d181 from performing
his duties accordingly one day during
testing d-181 fell asleep in the middle
of an experiment and dropped an
important component to the object he was
working with which nearly set the entire
facility on fire after that d181 knew
that something had to change d181
recognized the dolls there were
instances of
scp-2386 which he had worked with
previously in fact it was the
experiments with scp-2386 that injured
d-181 on his right arm causing an
infectious spot to crop up what caused
this and what exactly is
scp-2386 we'll get to all of that soon
enough but we need to focus on the
dreams it was three weeks into the
dreams three weeks since d181 was
injured during testing and three weeks
since d181 had a good night's sleep he
met with Dr Shaw the head researcher in
charge of
scp-2386 experimentation and someone who
worked with d181 many times Dr Shaw and
d-181 sat down and prepared an interview
she began good morning b181 you say
you've been having recurring dreams d181
shuffled the new seat a bit Yeah High
doc ever since I got this thing it
wasn't that bad at first d181 of course
was talking about the red spot on his
arm Shaw asked him to explain the dreams
and d-181 did he explained how he would
be in his punk feeling almost awake but
not quite when giant versions of
scp-2386 would make their way into the
room they'd gather around his bed and
stare at him shouting things and
caressing his infected spot Dr Shaw
listened intently d181 was clearly
shaken up from relaying the experience
to another person he continued barely
able to hold himself together you see
something had changed the night before
d-181 spoke to Dr Shaw for the first
time the dream was altered actually last
night they did something different
another one came in it had something
with it looked like a baby one it was
all wrapped up in this white cloth they
said something about wanting to show me
what I was working towards they pulled
back the cloth over its head and it was
a bug's head look me right the heck up a
baby with a bug's head was definitely
strange imagery but Dr Shaw was unsure
what it all could mean she knew scp-2386
were insect-like and with the way d181's
infection was looking her brain began
concocting a strange but potentially
true theory one that wasn't looking good
for d181 but before we get into that
let's talk about what scp-23 386 really
is they're known among Foundation
Personnel at site 32 as Pink Ladies and
there are diminutive species that
outwardly resembles Patchwork dolls made
of traditional fabric think that creepy
raggedy and doll your grandmother has
but 10 times more degraded a whole lot
more pink and straight up insectoid in
nature they're not as big as the ones in
d181's dream but they're actually as
scary with stitched on faces and a pair
of moth Wings on their backs in fact the
actual
scp-2386 instances range from only 7 to
9 centimeters tall autopsies on dead
instances of scp-2386 showed
resemblances to human botflies and
silkworms two species of insects that
are absolutely nasty it is terrifying to
imagine something so outwardly cuddly
could look so downright ugly on the
inside but that's what
scp-2386 are but don't try hugging them
either their cotton fiber exoskeleton is
as durable as it is gross and they're
not the kind of cuddly doll you'd want
to take to bed at night in the wild
scp-2386 are found in hives resembling
similarly patterned seat cushions big
mounds of cloth host to tons of these
tiny Terrors with the biggest Hive the
foundation ever came across being the
size of a large sofa these hives are
commonly found near suburban
environments and sometimes even inside
occupied housing imagine coming home to
find a brand new sofa inside your house
and then realizing that it's actually
home to thousands of
scp-2386 instances when scp-2386 leaves
their colonies it is primarily to feed
on smaller insects and seek out hosts
for Reproductive purposes despite their
cute but gross appearances
scp-2386 become hostile if approached by
males of any species and will Target
them accordingly that's why site 32 only
employs male Personnel for testing
purposes as soon as they're within range
of a male subject
scp-2386 will outstretch one of its
appendages and extend a pair of
scissor-like Claws from it before
swarming the mail this is what happened
to d181 which resulted in the red
infected spot on his arm conversely
female subjects in the presence of
scp-2386 are treated entirely
differently with the instances caring
for them presenting them with small
gifts and attempting to play with them
during the spring and summer seasons
scp-2386 will enter their mating season
and cease their hostilities towards
males instead they'll treat them with
the same level of kindness they do with
females but this kindness is just a
front when given the opportunity
scp-2386 will slice a small incision
into the male's subject and pump them
full of about 30 to 65 eggs underneath
their skin within 24 hours the incised
area will resemble patterned cloth and
genetic tests reveal it to be composed
those are the same material as
scp-2386's hives in the weeks that
follow this area will spread across the
subject's body and eventually it will
open to reveal fully grown adult
instances of
scp-2386 who burst from the patchwork
skin Dr Shaw recognized that this is
what was happening to d181 and
immediately got him to site-32's medical
ward d-181 was strapped down to the
table and tried not to freak out over
what he knew was about to happen the
dreams were acting as a warning and
scp-2386 was clearly looking forward to
having d-181 bear the next generation of
insect dolls thankfully Dr Shaw caught
the infection before the patchwork skin
was able to fully take root meaning that
the eggs underneath d181's skin were
premature thankfully there was still
time surgery was carried out immediately
and the doctors weren't surprised to
discover a colony of premature
scp-2386 eggs underneath 181's arm they
were removed from the body and thrown
into storage for further research
purposes
d181 after waking up from the surgery
thanked Dr Shaw at least now he wouldn't
have to deal with those horrible dreams
and the stinging swollen sensation
underneath his arm unfortunately he was
still a d-class Personnel working for
the foundation and would have many more
intense experiences after this one the
d181's gratefulness would soon subside
within a few hours d-181 began to ask Dr
Shaw if he could see
scp-2386's enclosure he spent the past
few weeks absolutely terrified of the
species but for whatever reason he felt
like he had unfinished business with the
anomalies he wanted to see them again Dr
Shaw became suspicious and
understandably denied d181 entrance from
the enclosure but this wasn't enough
d-181 became violent and tried to force
himself into the containment chamber he
needed to see them he could didn't
explain why but he felt incomplete
eventually d181 was subdued and returned
to his quarters but his symptoms
continued throughout the weeks he was
depressed and frequently made reference
to
scp-2386 as being lost or unrightfully
taken away from him to Dr Shaw what was
happening was clear d-181 had been
affected mentally upon receiving the
scp-2386 eggs this was a safety
mechanism induced by the anomaly in case
of birthing complications so d-181 would
feel compelled to receive another batch
of eggs into his body if the first batch
was lost or damaged it was disgusting
and Shaw was positive it would subside
after a few more weeks but what kept her
up at night wasn't the same dreams d-181
had or the terror of
scp-2386 it was the image of d181 scared
and out of his mind clawing that
containment chamber door begging to be
used as a host for s
2386's next batch of eggs when you see
some of the monsters and entities they
try to contain it's easy to think of the
SCP Foundation as the good guys and
granted When You observe the magnitude
of threats like the Scarlet King it's
hard for anyone to not look like a
downright moral Paragon in comparison
but the foundation aren't always knights
in shining armor sometimes they
themselves have committed horrific
atrocities in order to keep their
Supernatural subjects under wraps and
keep the rest of us safe from anomalous
Terror nowhere is that more clear than a
deadly incident that occurred in 2010
the foundation had been aware of the
Slow Burn sloth for decades and many
believe that the entity has existed for
as long as human beings have consumed
visual media movies TV web pages and
even print media like books and
magazines are vulnerable technically
speaking the name
scp-2774 refers to whatever visual
medium is currently holding the true
entity known as
scp-2774-a thankfully
scp-2774-a has never made it onto the
internet where it could do truly
catastrophic damage but the foundation
has prepared for that possibility
they've invented a software program web
crawler a03 g32 designed to constantly
monitor all forms of online visual media
for an appearance of
scp-2774-a so what is
scp-2774-a what could possibly be so
scary that even a picture of it leaking
onto the internet could potentially lead
to the collapse of human civilization
simply put
scp-2774-a is this image of an unknown
humanoid entity in a bizarre sloth
costume while this picture may seem
harmless that's only because it's black
and white and any red or green Hues have
been neutralized from the image anyone
who isn't red green colorblind and
somehow accidentally sees the true
version of
scp-2774-a has a fate far worse than
death in store for them this is the same
fate that would befall almost the entire
population of the northern Canadian town
of Harper Ridge in 2010. the residents
of this small Township were waking up
and going about their mourning some were
getting ready for work others enjoying a
leisurely breakfast in front of the
television set all of those affected had
unknowingly made the deadly mistake of
watching the local news that morning
while the anchor droned on about some
Local Economic statistics and delivered
a dry advertisement for an upcoming town
Festival The Familiar image of something
in the sloth costume appeared briefly on
the set behind him most of the Harper
Ridge residents who viewed the broadcast
didn't even notice the sloth but in that
fateful instant almost every single one
of them was doomed the Slow Burn sloth
doesn't always affect everyone who sees
it Foundation scientists have found that
it generally only affects 40 of people
exposed to it and doesn't affect those
suffering from colorblindness at all
however one of the more frightening
details about the sloth which is
classified as a memetic image SCP for
its ability to spread and appear
randomly almost anywhere is that it
grows more powerful and more contagious
with every living victim it affects
after claiming a significant number of
new victims say from a small Canadian
Town
scp-2774-a's infection rate can rise to
as high as 60 percent or beyond the
residents of Harper Ridge made their own
Predator deadlier without even knowing
it at a nearby Foundation facility units
were already mobilizing it was too late
for those who had already seen the Slow
Burn sloth but others could potentially
be saved if the situation was contained
quickly in addition to the web crawler
constantly monitoring the internet the
SCP Foundation also had a huge number of
dedicated team scanning broadcasts
worldwide for potential instances of
scp-2774-a exposure when one of these
teams detected the sloth's presence in
Harper's ridge's morning newscast and
found that upwards of 4 000 civilians
had already been exposed they knew there
was no time to waste back in Harper
Ridge the situation was already
deteriorating a few hours had passed
since the broadcast and those who were
exposed were beginning to experience
strange symptoms already first it was a
sense of tiredness and lethargy then an
unusual heaviness to their body as
though they were experiencing sudden
extreme muscle fatigue people exposed to
scp-2774-a also experienced clouded
cognition even thinking straight became
a real struggle it was at this point
that the true effects of witnessing the
Slow Burn sloth began to take hold
around six hours after initial exposure
little by little the infected lost all
cognitive functions and high higher
level decision-making abilities their
bodies still acted out basic movements
very slowly seemingly just as a result
of muscle memory but they had no control
over what was going on they became
essentially living zombies trapped in
their own bodies and only dimly aware of
it this horrifying experience was
completely consistent with prior
Foundation Research into the effects of
viewing
scp-2774-a and in a Twist almost crueler
than permanent zombification victims of
the Slow Burn sloth are randomly
allocated around 150 seconds of Lucidity
every 24 hours before being forced back
into their zombified state just as four
thousand of Harper ridge's residents
were beginning to experience these
effects all local communication channels
to the town were cut off by the
foundation well-equipped teams of mobile
task force operators began arriving on
the scene shortly after accompanied by a
number of containment units in the form
of buses and trucks lucky for them the
zombified victims of the Slow Burn sloth
were incredibly docile and compliant by
Nature shepherding all four thousand of
them into the containment units were
almost like working with cattle some
non-infected local residents attempted
to protest the sudden Abduction of their
zombified loved ones these residents
were subdued and either had their
memories wiped with Foundation amnestics
or were terminated on site like with
almost any conceivable situation the SCP
Foundation already had measures in place
for a mass exposure event like this all
in all a mere 4000 was still on the low
end of the potential infection scale the
four thousand victims were secretly
taken to site 116 a foundation testing
site under the direction of Dr Martin
and his second in command Dr Clara Chong
there they'd already been pursuing
research on approximately 2 400 infected
subjects from prior incidents including
Foundation Personnel who were
accidentally infected during the
monitoring process thus far it seemed
that the condition caused by witnessing
the Slow Burn sloth was incurable and
with 6400 known living victims situated
at site 116.
scp-2774-a was at an unprecedented level
of power all site Personnel were
instructed to proceed with caution and
carefully observe the behavior of their
new test subjects Dr Chung spearheaded
the majority of the Hands-On Research
into the infected residence of Harper
Ridge and observe some interesting
phenomenon in the victim's behavioral
patterns as the condition escalated the
infected subjects even in their largely
zombified State developed an almost
fanatically religious obsession with the
image of the Slow Burn sloth when left
to their own devices they would create
Idols of
scp-2774-a these included amateur
sculptures made of hoarded garbage
images drawn of the sloth with any
materials they could get their hands on
or even writing obsessively about the
sloth Dr Chung speculated that this
Behavior was perhaps an act of
appeasement on the victim's part hoping
to somehow save the Slow Burn sloth and
lessen its effects on them through
worship however she would later find out
that the truth of the matter was far
more disturbing initially due to their
largely docile States the subjects
imprisoned in site 116 were given a
relatively Long Leash the subjects were
even allocated two hours a day for
social interaction with fellow subjects
at meal times and during a designated
recreational period during these times
the subjects would often trade their
Slow Burn sloth Effigies with one
another however Dr Chung revoked the
social interaction periods and began
confining the subjects to separate
euclid-class containment cells when
violence began to break out between them
it became clear that during their 152nd
periods of Lucidity every 24 hours the
subjects would become extremely
distressed agitated and even aggressive
Dr Chung also ordered any Idols from
trash sculptures to Doodles and notes on
fragmented scraps of paper to be
destroyed it immediately at its new
increased power the foundation became
concerned that
scp-2774-a may develop the power to
manifest through these images no
meaningful Headway was being made on a
cure for the condition so something
needed to be done before the situation
got out of hand in hopes of gaining a
better understanding of the internal
processes of Slow Burn sloth victims Dr
Chung decided to conduct a series of
interviews with the subjects under her
care two such subjects subject 0866 AKA
David and subject 744 AKA Claire were
isolated for a 24-hour period in hopes
of catching them during their daily 150
seconds of Lucidity Dr Chung and the
foundation found the results of these
two interviews to be as Illuminating as
they were utterly terrifying when David
regained Lucidity he was in a state of
extreme agitation and showed an
unsettling fixation on the clock in the
site 116 interview room under direct
questioning from Dr Chong he revealed
that Slow Burn sloth victims are fully
aware of what's happening during their
zombified periods he compared the
sensation to being a passenger trapped
and bound in a vehicle over which they
have no control however in this state
victims are also unable to hold a
thought consistently for longer than
five seconds this leaves them in an
almost constant state of disorientation
worse still David describes that victims
are subjected to near constant
hallucinations of the original sloth
image guiding and controlling their
movements almost like a puppeteer thanks
to the clock David was aware of when his
150 seconds of Lucidity were about to
come to an end after apologizing for
what he was about to do David lunged at
Dr Chung causing a guard present in the
interview room to shoot him dead for Dr
Chung's protection Dr Chung's interview
with Claire echoed the same sentiment
during her 150 seconds of Lucidity
Claire first begged to be killed before
divulging further details about the
zombification stage she would describe
hallucinations of the Slow Burn sloth
stalking her constantly and controlling
her movements in some cases the sloth
would force her to open her eyes all
night while it stands next to her bed
and screams at her as Claire's 150
seconds of Lucidity ended and she became
non-responsive Dr Chung put in a request
for Claire's termination a request that
was fulfilled three days later the third
interview with subject 9225 also known
as Jason showed that
scp-2774-a appeared to be manually
starting the fights between the subjects
perhaps even for its own sadistic
Amusement he also stated before the
interview's conclusion that the image of
the sloth and his hallucinations was
becoming darker and more tangible almost
like it was becoming a real physical
being which was an unprecedented
phenomenon Dr Chung was for the first
time in a while truly afraid it seemed
by all accounts that scp-277 24-a's
power was growing considerably as a
result of its huge number of active
victims its infection rate had likely
risen well above 40 percent and its
ability to manifest would likely be on
the rise too if the Slow Burn sloth was
able to manifest on a national broadcast
Millions would be infected to truly
apocalyptic results Dr Chung only saw
one solution that might curtail the
entity's growing power but it wouldn't
be pretty she devised a procedure known
as procedure xxj9 as part of the
procedure additional staff were brought
into site-116 immediately the real
purpose of the plan was revealed shortly
afterward to reduce the number of active
subjects on site from 6400 to a mere 200
in hopes of reducing risk over the next
several days staff at site 116 engaged
in the gruesome task of executing around
6 200 infected subjects via lethal
injection this was an atrocity so
horrific even by SCP Foundation
standards that Dr Chung allowed the
parties involved to use Class A
amnestics to erase their memories of
being involved in the mass murder of
site 116 subjects in the aftermath of
the call the foundation did report a
decrease in
scp-2774-a's manifestations so Dr
Chung's procedure did indeed work just
at a heavy human toll the tragic
incident of the 2010 Harper Ridge
scp-2774 Containment Breach is a grim
reminder of just how far the SCP
Foundation is willing to go to do their
job and a reminder to be careful where
you look because some images have a much
more lasting impact than others imagine
if you could predict the future not
perfectly mind you but with enough
accuracy that brilliant enough Minds say
the best and brightest of the SCP
Foundation could plausibly reverse
engineer the main determinative factors
that caused a certain timeline line to
form imagine if through carefully
studying these determinative factors the
foundation could carefully shape the
future into one that's more favorable
for the human race than all the
Alternatives the preferred option if you
will would this not be advantageous your
next question is a very natural one
given the circumstances how does one
predict the future in such a manner well
the answer is uncomplicated but that
doesn't by any means make it easy you go
there spend a few months looking around
and then come back to report your
findings that's right folks we're not
talking psychics and seers here prepare
to expand your mind and please don't
worry if it all gets a little timey
whimy because
scp-2003 is the SCP foundation's
self-made time machine even most of the
staff at the SCP Foundation itself don't
know much about scp-2003 given the
highly sensitive nature of the projects
surrounding it much like scp-2000 is a
trump card securing our present in the
case of a catastrophic XK Class end of
the world scenario
scp-2003 is our prophylactic for such a
thing happening in the foreseeable
future what's far more unique about
scp-2003 is that the SCP Foundation
created this Ace in the Hole from
scratch the scp-2003 time machine was
invented over a 25-year period by
reverse engineering the anomalous
technology of three different classified
anomalies and retrofitting them into our
own non-anomalous framework the massive
machine is housed in armed site-47 a
remote and well-guarded facility
disguised as an oil refinery while
extensive records of scp-2003's
construction have been made by the
foundation and it stands to reason that
the machine could be reliably and
successfully reproduced in a different
context even the most intelligent
scientists taking part in the project
couldn't explain how or why it actually
operates in the words of another mad
inventor it just works the operating
principle of scp-2003 are relatively
simple to understand it is able to break
the laws of the space-time Continuum by
immediately transporting anything or
anyone placed in its Central chamber to
some point in the chronological future
the subjects transported forwards will
remain in this future for several months
before instantaneously being transported
back to the exact location they were
standing in the future in order to
prevent some kind of unfortunate
accident like phasing back halfway
through a wall and becoming unpleasant
Modern Art the foundation has
established a secure facility for
travelers to head and wait out the rest
of their time when their mission is
complete through extensive testing
including that which was performed under
the purview of project xn Shepard the
foundation has discovered a great deal
about the nature of time travel via
scp-2003 will outline the most crucial
caveats here so what happens next makes
a lot more sense to you after all if
time travel was easy everyone would do
it first as we alluded to earlier the
data collected by scp-2003 on the nature
of the future is often unclear imprecise
and unreliable for example the data
collected from 2003 did provide
extremely useful in predicting and
preventing a massive security breach
over at site 19 in 1997. so naturally
when it predicted a devastating series
of earthquakes off the west coast of the
United States in 1999 an event that
several agents sent through scp-2003
observed directly it came as a shock to
everyone when nothing happened the
foundation discovered following this
that all Productions needed to be
contextualized through heaps of metadata
for it to be of any real use in
predicting or preventing our specific
future the foundation also discovered
that certain individuals had a strangely
disproportionate effect on the unfolding
of future your events let's say for
example scp-2003 discovers that a new
type of nuclear weapon will be invented
in 2028 and quickly adopted by a number
of leading Nations by 2030 and by 2035
tensions will rise Sabers will Rattle
and this nuclear weapon will be used on
mass to destroy human society as we know
it naturally in order to prevent this
the foundation might see to it that
certain groups of nuclear scientists
certain generals and certain world
leaders get liquidated and yet another
trip into the future shows that this
massive nuclear war was not averted but
why because it just so happens that this
event was inexplicably tied to the birth
of a little boy named James Hoskins in
Saskatoon Circa 2025 despite little
Jimmy Hoskins seemingly having nothing
to do with the actual development of the
technology seeing as he's only 10 years
old when the bombs start falling the
foundation scientists working under
Project X and Shepherd keep a database
of all these highly determinative
individual visuals also known as
magnifier individuals so they can keep
tabs on how they're affecting any future
timelines speaking of future timelines
we're afraid to tell you that this
penultimate caveat isn't exactly a
pleasant one there are few to any
cohesive future timelines where Humanity
survives long term bummer right the
foundation calls these loose timelines
determinative sets and in the majority
of them human civilization collapses all
humans die and in some cases the Earth
becomes completely uninhabitable to all
forms of life the foundation is
currently seeking a more optimistic
option through controlled manipulations
of the Casual stream in our time but
currently all we have is the preferred
option option xn and if you're someone
who would jump at the chance to travel
into the future and take a gander at all
the wondrous or terrifying sites there's
actually one pretty major caveat of
scp-2003 that we've been playing rather
close to the chest early Foundation
tests found out that the time travel
process via scp-2003 is extremely
damaging to plant and animal tissue
rather than just going on a wacky time
travel Adventure like Doctor Who or
Austin Powers it'd be a little more like
stepping into a giant microwave while
dressed in a spacesuit made of aluminum
foil you're gonna die a horrible death
but there is one silver lining well
maybe not silver from your perspective
probably more like pewter the foundation
has discovered a way to viably send
human adjacent subjects through time
with scp-2003 without instantaneous
death we just can't promise that you're
going to like it you see the one kind of
organic tissue that seems to survive the
scp-2003 time travel process is the
human brain and nervous system due to
the highly controlled nature of Project
X and Shepard the foundation can't just
send in d-classes to do the job they
instead use actual agents though mostly
ones who are nearing or Beyond
retirement or are suffering from a
terminal illness these agents are dosed
on a course of anti-anxiety
antidepressant and antipsychotic
chemotherapy to toughen their minds for
the horrors to come though the exact
nature of these Horrors is kept secret
from them until it's already happened
you may be familiar with one of the
foundation's most well-known front
companies Boston Dynamics as well as one
of their most famous products the
robotic quadrupedal probe known as Big
Dog well in order to send a sentient
being through time without them being
completely destroyed by a CP 2003 the
agent's brain and nervous system are
entirely removed from their body and
transported into the body of a modified
big dog still think it'd be fun to time
travel hey don't look so nervous for
everyone who agrees to be part of an
scp-2003 Mission and survives you'll get
one hell of a pension or at least your
family will if that's any consolation
now that you understand all this let's
come clean about this mysterious Project
X and Shepherd we've been alluding to
throughout the video it all started with
a letter to the heads of the scp-2003
research project from 05-7 a member of
the legendary o5 Council that instructs
the foundation in all that it does the
letter read up until this point all
attempts at Future intervention using
scp-2003 have been Limited in scope and
Scatter shot in nature I have seen the
wisdom in this approach it is informed
by painstaking contingency planning and
risk benefit evaluation the past 18
months of reports however have promise
if you are bold enough to seize the
initiative we may have found a way out
here the price so there's always a
surprise as you fell know consider this
note an official change in policy as of
today all efforts at intervention are
now aimed at bringing about and
preserving xn designated magnifier
individuals associated with xn are to be
protected from undue interference at the
expense of all other priorities in
particular nurudyang must be allowed to
die in the manner most observations have
predicted for her if anything at all
changes in that regard make it happen I
trust that you're familiar enough is the
rest of the determinative sets to
understand why we're going this way so
in short of all the potential timelines
o5-7 wants the researchers assigned to
scp-2003 to ensure that the timeline xn
is the one that actually comes to be
seeing as it's preferable to the
Alternatives hence Project X and Shepard
you're probably wondering what happens
in Timeline xn that makes it the most
desirable outcome possible well things
continue as normal everything from
anomalous activity to social unrest to
environmental factors stay pretty much
the same as time goes on until 2349 when
a giant 22 kilometer asteroid strikes
the Earth and wipes out the majority of
humanity in an instant following this
the world becomes unfit for human
habitation hey don't look so glum you'll
all be dead by then well except Dr
bright sorry again jack we at least get
a nice three centuries before we're
wiped from the cosmic table your next
question is probably if the preferred
option has Humanity being wiped out by a
giant asteroid in a little over 300
years what are all the other ones aren't
we entitled to a multiple choice future
if we don't feel comfortable with being
completely annihilated by an asteroid
before we're even halfway to the year
3000 well we'll give you a little
tasting platter of potential timelines
and you can take your pick there was the
narrowly avoided scenario XB where
things progressed in a similar fashion
to scenario xn except a massive
gamma-ray burst from the Sun in April
2017 wiped out all life on Earth within
38 seconds then there's scenario XE
where the birth of an unnamed boy in
Turkmenistan combined with the election
of Sir William Entwistle as prime
minister of New Zealand in 2049 leads to
a world destroying nuclear Exchange
change between Israel and greater
Indonesia in 2058 any attempts to stop
it just make it happen sooner or what
about scenario X age here A Deadly
mutated form of influenza causes the
deaths of over a billion people
worldwide combating this threat causes
increased cooperation between World
governments that actually resulted in a
huge net Improvement for Global Peace
and quality of life it seems unrealistic
we know but scp-2003 doesn't lie however
despite things going well all known life
on Earth just vanishes on July 29 2059.
it's a hell of an unpleasant twist after
things start going so well for once in
scenario XO the anomalous increases in
frequency and magnitude in 2037 this
leads to a broken masquerade scenario
where the foundation's web of secrecy
collapses and anomalous chaos Reigns
across the globe the foundation's
members are hunted and killed and World
governments attempting to weaponize the
anomalous leads to a new arms race that
wipes out all Humanity by 25 48 or maybe
scenario XU is more your cup of tea in
this one the sun collapses leading to
Eternal darkness and massive temperature
drops inexplicably humans still survive
but are in a state of constant unmoving
Agony and maybe if you just really love
spiders you'll get a kick out of
scenario XX where a mysterious
pathogenic protist causes the majority
of humanity to fall in love with the
Brazilian wandering spider one of the
few spiders that pose an actual threat
to humans the diverting of all resources
meant to keep humans alive to instead
breeding the spiders combined with many
many many many people being killed by
the resulting spiders leads to 6 billion
deaths in the early 2030s but hey you'll
get to see some pretty great spiders if
that's your thing I guess scenario xn is
hardly a picnic nobody likes the idea of
facing an Armageddon straight out of
Armageddon when that asteroid kills all
life on Earth in 300 years but while it
it undeniably isn't perfect it may just
be the best option we've got ah isn't
the future amazing Russell's Back was
pressed against the wall his shuddering
hands gripping the fire ax the low
emergency lighting filling the corridor
indicated the lockdown was still in
effect although that was simultaneously
a blessing and a curse sure it meant
that thing couldn't get out hopefully
but it also meant that Russell was stuck
in the wing of the facility with it he
had no idea if anyone else was left he
hadn't seen what had happened to
Carpenter maybe it got him or perhaps he
had managed to give it the slip at the
last second there was no way of knowing
for sure it had all started so simply so
innocently and with such Noble
intentions if he had known it would lead
to all this madness Russell would have
never put his name down on the request
form the SCP Foundation had been working
on a way to neutralize or cure scp-610
for what felt like ever to one team of
scientists the infamously so-called
flesh that hates was a fascinating
organism it was a highly contagious
sarcic skin disease isolated entirely
within the small area of Siberia that on
its own wasn't enough to Peak the
interest of the research team led by Dr
Carpenter including his hand-picked star
researchers Russell and David along with
their assistant clennan and Dr bottin an
expert on infectious diseases who had
recently joined their efforts to provide
his specialist knowledge what did
Captivate all of them however was what
scp-610 did when it infected a human
being the disease would trigger
aggressive and uncontrollable mutations
within its infected and could virtually
rewrite their entire physiology in a
heartbeat the flesh that hates was
capable of transforming a person's body
into a horrifying fleshy mass of Limbs
and matter that barely resemble the
human being anymore and in addition the
in fact individuals would retain some
level of awareness attacking any
uninfected person with extreme hostility
there had long been chatter among some
other research teams studying scp-610
about devising a way to weaponize the
disease if they could somehow create a
variant that didn't turn people into
monsters or at least cause the fleshy
Abominations to die shortly after
mutation then the foundation or another
interested party could deploy the flesh
that hates as a biological weapon Dr
Carpenter had long abhorred the idea
instead searching for a way to
completely reverse the effects of an
scp-610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in their
research the team were beginning to lose
home researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried treating scp-610 like a common
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr button's
input and granted that approach had
taught them a lot about the flesh's
ability to contaminate a subject from a
single cell but this infection was
anomalous through and through could the
solution to eradicating it for good lie
not in a medical cure but in another SCP
Russell brought this hypothesis to the
rest of the research team and each of
them had suggestions for other anomalies
they could potentially use to cure a
subject of the flesh that hates we could
get scp-049 to take a look at the
infected patient clenin suggested oh
might work Carpenter mused although even
if he cares someone he might also kill
them he has his old deal about ridding
the world of the pestilence could prove
to be a problem there's always 682 David
said dryly have the reptile eat up all
the scp-610 infectis and voila problem
solved a real helpful David researcher
Russell retorted and what are we gonna
do when scp-682 adapts to the flesh you
really want an infected Immortal lizard
on the loose Gentlemen please Dr Button
spoke up we're forgetting one obvious
option I propose we submit a joint
formal request to use scp-914 for this
experiment unanimously the group all
agreed that this was the best course of
action
scp-914 or the Clockworks was a giant
machine with two booths marked input and
output although the foundation still
couldn't fully comprehend exactly how as
cp914 seem to take any object placed
within it and disassemble recreate
improve or destroy the item depending on
its current setting there was one issue
however a prior failed experiment where
in a d-class was placed in scp-914 had
led to some pretty disastrous
consequences as a result ever since no
organic matter was to be placed within
the Clockworks a rule that the teams
experiment with the flesh would breach
still they pressed on each of the five
researchers signing their request to
utilize scp-914 before it was submitted
to the foundation higher ups within
hours the request was denied but the
team was determined that scp-914 could
be the key to solving the foundation's
long-standing issue with scp-610 Dr
Carpenter repealed the decision
urging the higher-ups to reconsider he
argued that this flouting of the no
organic matter rule was necessary to
potentially rid the world of the flesh
that hates after a few days of
consideration the request was finally
Faithfully granted the team went to work
immediately requisitioning two test
subjects both of which had suffered
scp-610 infections and were
mutated the pair of them were deemed a
potential Hazard to every member of
foundation staff on site and as a result
the entire wing of the facility where
the Clockworks was housed had to be
evacuated for safety dressed in
biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers used an electric cattle
prod to coax the first flesh specimen
into the input chamber of scp-914 this
was the test run they wanted to see if
the Clockworks would actually be able to
affect those infected with scp-610 at
all plus they needed a Fail-Safe just in
case something went wrong and luckily
the machine had just the thing Russell
asked Clemen to set the Clockworks to
rough and with a click in War of its
numerous gears and Gyros
scp-914 came to life instantly the
infected test subject was completely
obliterated the setting had reduced it
to atoms disintegrating it on such a
microscopic level that there was nothing
left in the output chamber the second
infected creature seemed to bristle with
anger but didn't or become aggressive as
it too was plotted towards the
Clockworks next perhaps out of fear that
their Theory might be wrong the team
agreed to set scp-914 to its one-to-one
setting sure enough the machine
recreated another instance of a specimen
infected with the flesh that hates
replacing the previous one we all know
we're stalling researcher David piped up
let's do what we came here for set the
Clockworks to coarse nervously receding
a nod from Dr Carpenter fun and stepped
forward to switch the dial on scp-914 to
the course setting this was the primary
reason the team had all agreed to use
the machine on a flesh specimen this
setting could disassemble any item
placed in the input Booth separating it
into its base components botton had
suggested the use of scp-914 based on
the theory that if it worked correctly
the Clockworks could extract the flesh
that hates from its infected host
rendering them free of the disease the
machine made a colossal amount of noise
as Clinton hurried back to a safe
distance with the others but as it was
powering up seconds from activating Dr
Carpenter noticed something the color
drained from his face as he saw it none
of the others had noticed from a
distance that the dial hadn't been set
to course instead it pointed to very
fine the highest refinement setting 914
had what the hell have you done
Carpenter yelled at clennan before the
machine suddenly activated would step
free from the output Booth stunned the
researcher it was a man a seemingly
ordinary human who had presumably been
infected by scp-610 some time ago he
stepped nervously out of the machine
looking confused for a moment as a para
Foundation security guards cautiously
approached him we did it Russell said in
awe suddenly fleshy tendrils burst forth
from the man's arms latching on to the
approaching guards they screamed in
agony their bodies melting become a
bloody misshapen mass that stayed
attached to the humanoid creature at the
center it was like they became a part of
it the guards arms and legs forming
additional limbs as their forms were
reconstituted and repurposed as part of
a monster that was now crawling on its
six legs towards the research team in a
blind panic the group scrambled for the
entrance the head of the infected man
splitting open down the middle opening
up into a wide snapping pair of Jaws
panting hard as he ran his breath
fogging up the clear faceplate of The
Biohazard suit Russell ran through the
door hearing someone close behind he
stopped for a moment looking back to see
the creature on the other side of the
door starting to spill through the door
frame like a liquid running faster
around a corner Russell came to another
halt in the common area a third security
guard following just before a thick
Steel security door came slamming down
sealing the creature on the other side
the other door didn't hold it what good
is that going to do researcher David
yelled more to the point Dr Carpenter
said turning and marching towards
Glennon he launched a furious punch at
the assistant knocking him to the floor
why did you set 914 to very fine clenin
the enraged doctor shouted you're the
one who Unleashed that Abomination you
maniac what Glennon replied fearfully
trembling I I didn't I swear I didn't it
said course I'm sure of it you expect us
to believe that was a mistake gentlemen
we need to focus on the situation at
hand the security officer interjected
regardless of who's responsible we need
to inform the foundation higher-ups
there's an emergency lockdown Russell
replied it would have triggered the
moment the scp-610 specimen got free
you've trapped us with a monster clenin
Dr Carpenter spat hold on researcher
David spoke up wasn't it botton's idea
to use 914 in the first place the common
area felt silent as everyone turned to
look at Dr Barton did you plan for this
doc David pushed Bond chuckled need I
remind you my friends that we all agreed
to use the Clockworks did we not all of
our names are on the request he answered
besides accusing me David that's rather
Rich coming from you what's that
supposed to mean the researcher fired
back beckoning his finger botton
encouraged the rest of the team to
follow him across the common area to
where a row of lockers stood each door
bearing one of their names he gestured
to the one labeled David go on button
added shooting him a dirty look David
barch passed the disease expert and
opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leather-bound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying scp-610 the
researchers all knew a text on sarcasism
when they saw one it had been long known
that the flesh that hates was often
described in text revered by sarkic
Colts who worshiped death Decay and
disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a
sarkist carpenter asked the fury in his
voice already elevating no I'm not
researcher David protested I've never
seen that before it was in your locker
the doctor yelled you're one of those
cannibal cultists this was your plan to
refine the flesh from your Twisted death
worshiping religion it certainly seems
that way button interjected after all
researcher David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even
you David pointed at the doctor you
planted this in my locker you're here a
sarkist clennan repeated in a nervous
stammer you made me turn the dial to
very fine you made that thing appear you
made me your accomplice anchor tears
streamed on his face Clinton's hand
reached for the security officer's gun
and went to draw it planning to shoot
David on the spot but as he went to pull
the weapon from the guard's holster it
wouldn't budge it was then that
assisting Clemens stared in horror at
his hand his fingers had fused to the
guard's leg the officer gave a twisted
grin as his torso burst open tendrils of
Flesh latching onto clenin and
assimilating him just like it had done
before the flesh creature broke down its
victim's body making it a new part of
itself a grotesque mass of Limbs and
bloody matter littered with the
discarded faces of those it had infected
the research team looked at it terrified
their stomach's turning disgusted at the
growing growling abomination of bodies
fused to one another oh you're beautiful
Russell heard of voice whisper behind
him he turned to see Barton looking at
the scp-610 creature and smiling
researcher David was the closest and the
creature lunched at him pulling his leg
out from under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh it pulled him
in his body stretching his skin tearing
and Bones snapping as he became part of
it a new set of Limbs added to the
monster Dr Carpenter went to try and
pull him free but it was already too
late but he stepped back knowing that if
he touched it he would be infected too
the sound of running caught Russell's
attention and he spotted botton making a
break for it grabbing Dr Carpenter by
the sleeve the researcher pulled him in
the same direction partly running away
from the flesh as it assimilated David
and partly Chasing The sarkic Saboteur
the pair of them quickly caught up to
botton leaning over himself and panting
breathlessly thank God you two made it
he wheezed after the run I can't believe
David could do this to unleash this
nightmare upon us Russell thought to
snap at him to scream how dare he keep
lying but Barton's back was to him now
he'd never get a better chance there was
a cabinet on the corridor wall
containing a fire ax for emergencies as
carefully and quietly as he could
Russell fished the ax out of its case
while Spartan and carpenter were looking
away we should get the foundation to
lift the lockdown Bond was saying they
need to let us out and then oh he let
out a blood curdling scream mid-sentence
as the ax blade wounded him Russell
pulled it back standing over the doctor
as he fell to the floor in agony Russell
have you lost your mind Carpenter
exclaimed no doctor he's the cultist I
have no idea how he tricked Glennon but
that flesh creature exists because of
him the researcher answered from the
floor unable to move thanks to his
injury Dr botton began to laugh it took
me years to infiltrate the foundation so
much time waiting to gain access to that
blessed flesh and now you've helped me
to refine it to create its ultimate
would fall you want to kill me go ahead
Russell my life doesn't matter for once
that creature is free it will bring
about a new age of Flesh and Grand
consist iron will reward me for the role
I played in unleashing it David was
right Carpenter realized button you
you've planted that book on him to throw
us off doctor we need to think of
something researcher Russell interjected
ax still in hand nobody knows more about
the flesh that hates than us there must
be a way to kill that thing otherwise if
it gets out of this lockdown it could
spread to everyone in the foundation
what about fire that's been effective
against 610 infecties before right yes
yes but the doctor desperately tried to
think this new being we've created he
created Russell argued looking at the
grimacing wounded button we cannot deny
the role we've all played in this
researcher Carpenter argued and we have
no idea if it possesses the same
weaknesses as the flesh before its
refinement but we have to try sir the
researcher protested of course I agree
the sickening sound of a slithering
slick Mass was rapidly approaching still
laying on the floor in pain Dr botton
had been dragged to the middle of a
junction with Carpenter and Russell
hiding around either Corner suddenly
botton started hollering as the flesh
came into view practically calling it to
him oh look at you he exclaimed you're
better than I could have ever hoped for
looking down at him with the faces it
had collected the creature stabbed one
of its disgusting appendages through
botton drawing its body into its growing
form I am honored to give my life so
that the age of Flesh May begin the
doctor said weekly through the pain as
he was infected from around the corner
Carpenter had taken the sarkic text and
set its pages on fire with a cigarette
lighter turning to the creature he
hurled the massive burning paper at it
hoping it would be enough fire to spread
to the flesh while it was assimilating
botton who they had left there as paint
the fiery book collided with the
monstrosity as Russell peeked around the
corner he saw the flesh retreating from
the Flames button's body now added to it
for a moment it seemed like the creature
was afraid of the fire but slowly it
drew nearer and nearer to the book with
ease it stamped down the Flames with
button's leg dowsing the fire and
suffering no damage to it at all
gripping the ax in his hands Russell
went to charge the creature only to feel
something push him back Dr Carpenter had
stopped him run he yelled instantly
Russell turned and raced down the
corridor the sound of fleshy tentacles
whipping through the air he dared not
look back just in case the monster was
right behind him eventually he reached
another corner and slammed his back
against it hand shuddering as he held on
to the fire ax he had no idea what had
happened to Carpenter maybe it got him
or perhaps he had managed to give it the
slip at the last second Russell came a
hush voice from around the corner one
the researcher recognized he turned to
see Dr Carpenter approaching him
sneaking like he was trying to avoid
being heard I think I'd managed to give
it the slip doctor whispered for a
second Russell backed up his hands
tightening around the ax handle this
might have looked like Dr Carpenter but
was it are you really you doctor he
asked of course I am Carpenter replied
think that I'm not that monstrosity
Russell raised the ax defensively only
to notice the sadness in the doctor's
face unable to bring himself to swing
even to find out the researcher lowered
his weapon Carpenter looked grateful
come on come on let's get them to lift
this lockdown you said I'm sure an MTF
can step in and take care of our mistake
as the pair of them cautiously made
their way towards one of the locked
doors Dr Carpenter reached out a hand to
place it on Russell's shoulder ever
since she was in high school Faith had
dreamed of moving out and finally
getting a place of her own it wasn't
that she didn't love her parents she did
but they were always around always
coming into her room without knocking
telling her when to go to bed when to
wake up not to eat dinner in front of
the TV in college she had some welcome
Independence but she had to live with
roommates again they were perfectly nice
people some of them she even considered
good friends but she hated having to
share her space having to come home from
a long day of classes and see someone
else's dishes piled up in the sink to
have someone else's music keeping her
awake at night to delay her morning
shower because someone else had gotten
there first so she was thrilled when a
few years after graduating she got a new
job at a marketing company that would
finally let her afford a place by
herself at last she could have some
peace some quiet and most importantly
some privacy Faith spent all day moving
furniture and unpacking boxes turning
the little apartment into a real home it
wasn't much just a main room she used as
a bedroom and living room a bathroom and
a basic little kitchen but it was all
hers and all of the little personal
touches she'd put together really made
it feel like the place was meant for her
there was the orange couch she picked up
at a vintage store downtown the coffee
table she'd gotten for free from her
last roommate framed pictures of her
family and friends a bed with Linens in
her favorite color light blue and lots
and lots of potted plants over time she
would find even more things more little
personal touches to liven up the space
now how to celebrate her new home her
gas wasn't on yet so she could cook
anything but that was the perfect excuse
to order in 30 minutes or less later she
was kicking back on her couch with a
large cheese pizza watching a scary
movie on her TV no one would ask to
switch it over to the bachelor no one
would take the last slice while she was
in the bathroom it was perfect finally A
Little Piece of Heaven an introverts
Paradise as she finished her first meal
in the new place she felt her eyes
beginning to grow heavy the day of
strenuous unpacking catching up with her
body just as she was thinking about
calling it a night a pale-faced monster
appeared out of nowhere on screen
terrifying the movie's main character
and making Faith jump spilling her soda
all over the coffee table damn it she
groaned already she'd made a mess but
hey she tried to look on the bright side
it was yet another first to break in the
apartment she grabbed a kitchen towel to
mop up the soda and when she returned to
the main room she froze there was
something in the window standing out
against the darkness outside at first
she thought it was a reflection a trick
of the light but as she slowly
approached the window eyes wide and
hands trembling she got a better look
there was a face a little difficult to
make out as if it were peering Out of
the Shadows but unmistakable nonetheless
it was pale humid vaguely resembling a
strained man with dark circles under his
eyes and he was looking right at her she
didn't scream she was too terrified to
make a sound she stared at the face for
a long moment waiting for it to do
something anything after several moments
of the tenses staring contest of her
life she blinked the face didn't budge
yeah you need to leave she finally spoke
surprising herself as she did if you
don't get out of here I'm calling the
cops again the face did nothing do you
hear me her voice climbed in Pitch her
heart pounding against the inside of her
chest who was he what did he want she
became vaguely aware of the fact that
she couldn't see the rest of the man's
body just his face looking at her with a
neutral expression a look of vague
curiosity like someone watching a caged
animal at the zoo might have it was then
she remembered something that made her
blood run cold made the towel drop from
her hands as her stomach she lived on
the third floor her apartment had no
balcony no fire escape he could have
climbed up whatever was looking at her
through her window it was no ordinary
peeping Tom she couldn't say how long
she stared at the face its unblinking
eyes it's inscrucible expression she
moved closer to the window step by step
until she was almost nose to nose with
the thing she couldn't think of it as a
person though it looked like one mostly
she should run screaming out the door
looking for some kind of help but what
would she say that there was a floating
face looking at her through the window
what if it was somehow all in her head
some sort of hallucination brought on by
exhaustion and the stress of the move
she raised a fist and following a
passive Instinct wrapped on the glass
she didn't know what she expected for it
to Blink to move to knock back to say
something but nothing happened it just
stayed there as if it were part of the
window itself Faith pulled the curtains
closed hiding the strange face from view
with any luck it would be gone in the
morning she had worked hard to get this
apartment and she would be damned if she
let some strange thing whatever it was
drive her out of her new home but as she
climbed into bed and pulled the covers
up to her chin she could still feel its
Gaze on her as if it could see through
the thick fabric of the curtains she
rolled over onto her side her back to
the window and tried her best to forget
about it to shake that horrible feeling
of being observed she lay there for
hours eyes open heart racing but finally
the exhaustion one and she Slipped Away
into sleep she didn't dream at all that
night it was as if she closed her eyes
and seconds later it was morning she
woke to the beep of her alarm feeling as
if she hadn't rested at all the first
thing she did was climb out of the bed
and go to the window carefully
tentatively she opened the curtains she
let out a sigh of deep relief the face
was gone she must have imagined it after
all a bit concerning but as long as it
didn't happen again she wouldn't have
anything to worry about lack of sleep
does strange things to the mind after
all no longer plagues by the fear of
that strange face faith hopped into the
shower and let the worries of the
previous night wash away disappearing
down the drain she brushed her teeth
dried her hair did her makeup and
dressed for work after a banana and a
quick cup of coffee she was out the door
work was exceptionally busy that day and
it pushed any memory of the Oddity in
the window out of her mind entirely she
was even feeling good enough to accept
her friend's offer to grab a drink after
work they met up at a bar down the
street from her new place sharing
cocktails memories and a plate of onion
rings it was a perfect lovely evening by
the time she got home savoring the click
of the key in the lock as she let
herself into her quiet little Sanctuary
she had completely forgotten about the
unusual Apparition she's along the door
open and rushed to dump herself onto the
couch for a bit of TV before bed then
out of the corner of her eye she saw it
the face back in its previous Place
staring at her from the darkness outside
she gaffed at the site her screamed
catching in her throat it was just as
she remembered it right no something was
different what was it she clapped her
mouth in horror as she identified the
change its expression was different gong
was the vaguely interested neutral
expression now it was smiling at her not
a pleasant smile not a warm friendly
smile a wicked smile twisted and cruel
it knew she was afraid that she'd been
hoping it was gone forever and it was
enjoying itself her hands were shaking
nervous sweat beating on her brow what
do you want from me she whispered
staring into its eyes they didn't move
were they glittered with malicious Glee
just the same what do you want from me
she repeated her voice rising to a shout
shut up her next door neighbor yelled
banging on the wall it's after midnight
she couldn't bring herself to respond
she had more important things to attend
to her stomach turned bile rising in her
throat with the face begun again in the
morning would he come back again at
night was the apartment haunted
possessed by a specter doomed to reside
in a window forever was that why the
rent had been so affordable or maybe it
was her maybe this thing had been drawn
to her or maybe she was losing her mind
unaccustomed to living alone and her
sanity was slipping away she shivered at
the thought what was worse if the face
was on her head or if it wasn't rather
than attempt to answer the question
gnawing at her she closed the curtains
out of sight out of mind she thought she
would have to keep the curtain closed
possibly forever it was better than
seeing that damned face grinning that
horrible grin but as she tried to settle
in for another restless night she could
feel its eyes boring into her burning
into her skull she had never felt so
uneasy before she prepared for
cockroaches for black mold and for
burglars but not for this this was
something outside of her understanding
outside of reality itself just don't
look she whispered yourself just don't
look at it it became part of her daily
routine wake up ignore the window go to
work try to forget about the window get
home try desperately not to think about
the window she could always feel it
though as soon as the sun went down
though she kept the curtains closed she
knew it was there she thought about
checking to see what face it was making
this time but she couldn't bring herself
to look gradually her condition worsened
she woke up to a tightness in her chest
panic attacks that wrecked her body and
felt like her heart might stop beating
her stomach would ache she struggled to
keep food down one morning she rushed to
the bathroom and spat up blood the
effect began to follow her out of the
apartment too far away from the faces
dwelling she would sit at her desk
struggling to focus on marketing
campaigns and pitches and she would feel
a sudden pain in her stomach forcing her
to double over and groan with Agony she
would see flickers of the pale face in
her peripheral vision turning to look
only to find there was nothing
when she walked down the hall to the
elevator or down the street outside her
building she would feel as if someone
was following her she never saw anyone
never heard any footsteps coming up
behind her but she could never shake off
the sensation soon even her formerly
dreamless nights of sleep as fitful as
they had been became unsafe she would
toss and turn sweating through her
sheets as her subconscious was tormented
by chilling visions and terrible
nightmares she would dream of walking
down a long dark hallway that seemed to
go on forever and something coming up
behind her trying to grab her and drag
her away it would chase her wide dark
eyes and long long limbs grasping at her
as she ran and ran but never escaped
other times she would dream of being
locked in a damp basement chained to a
wall as the pale creature sat in a chair
across from her just watching waiting
for something though she didn't know
what every night another nightmare that
made her wake up screaming fighting off
invisible attackers after two weeks of
living in hell she decided to look out
the window again she had to see had to
know that night when she opened the
curtains it was there mouth wide open
eyes glinting it was laughing at her
screw the deposit enough was enough she
wanted her home back she picked up the
heavy lamp on her bedside table wounded
up and threw it out the window with all
her might the glass shattered little
crystalline Shard sprang in every
direction as the lamp flew through the
air out the window and down to the
street below and just like that the face
was gone she checked every other window
in place the little one in the bathroom
the people on her door but it was
nowhere to be found she was free her
knees gave out and she collapsed to the
floor her face in her hands and wept
from sheer relief tomorrow she would
clean up the broken glass and spin her
landlord a story about a freak accident
someone would come to fix the window and
it would be the best money she had ever
spent eventually the whole ordeal would
fade away from memory like a bad dream
but somewhere out there someone else was
living the nightmare all over again
looking out to darkened window to see an
unwelcome Guest The Entity known as
scp-965
scp-965 is a phenomenon affecting framed
windows when it appears it manifests in
the shape of a shadowy face belonging to
a pale man staring in through the window
the details of the man's face vary from
person to person as well as his apparent
age and the direction he is facing
however all reports point to the same
figure at various ages ranging from 10
to 55. the foundation has attempted to
use facial recognition software to
identify a citizen matching the
description of this figure but so far no
one has been found
scp-965 will not appear in just any
window it will only manifest when the
lighting on the outside of the window
drops below illumination of five
candalas the lighting on the inside of
the window does not have any measure
effect the face will only appear in the
confines of a completely assembled
window frame though the window does not
necessarily need to be installed
anywhere it will only move from one
glass pan to another if its original
point of manifestation is destroyed the
face can be seen from an outside vantage
point though it has been described by
observers as looking away into the room
when scp-965 first appears to someone it
produces feelings of unease anxiety and
low-grade paranoia anyone within the
visual range of the affected window will
experience these feelings even if the
window is covered by curtains or any
other means any individual that sleeps
in an area visible to
scp-965's manifestation point will begin
to experience difficulty sleeping
suffering from upsetting and disturbing
dreams however this is not the end point
of the entity's impact on those it
appears to at a point between 3 and 10
nights of sleep after its initial
appearance the entity's facial
expression will begin to shift into to a
noticeable smile after the shift the
victim's symptoms will become physical
as well as mental including ulcers and
intestinal bleeding heartburn abdominal
pain and even vomiting blood this has
been attributed to the entity's
influence on the human body's reaction
to heightened levels of stress and fear
the subjects that reach this stage of
exposure to scp-965 begin to see its
face in Windows in their dreams as well
as spotting it in their peripheral
vision while going about their Waking
Life they begin to see the face out of
the corner of their eye even when the
affected window is nowhere in sight
these additional sightings are
accompanied by lingering feelings of
paranoia and The Sensation that
something is following or watching them
though the entity has never made a sound
and does not move while it is visible it
can disappear and reappear in different
poses it has also displayed notable
signs of sentience appearing
disappointed when it manifests in an
empty room and angry if it sees someone
who broke its previous window when
presented with one of the agents who
first brought it into custody The Entity
appeared frightened for the first time
testing involving scp-965 involving the
destruction of its host window confirmed
that a multi-paned window might act as
multiple holding zones but significant
damage to its overall structure keeps it
from being a viable replacement in this
particular case the entity manifested in
a nearby experimentation Chambers
observation window which was promptly
destroyed in order to prevent any
potential breaches for a month following
this incident The Entity manifested with
noticeably hostile facial expressions
clearly resentful of its treatment only
one other notable incident has occurred
so far during the course of
scp-965's containment by the SCP
Foundation Dr Al the rest of her name
has been redacted from the official file
was the head researcher assigned to
scp-965 for several months before she
filed an official request for transfer
to a different test subject she was
beginning to experience intrusive
visions of scp-965 and lingering
feelings of paranoia lasting long after
she left the foundation signed her
symptoms were consistent with those of
someone who had slept in the presence of
the entity though she swore up and down
she had never napped or slept at all in
the vicinity of the affected window she
was temporarily relieved of her duties
and provided with psychological care so
far no other instances of scp-965
impacting staff who have not slept in
its presence have been reported but this
case set an unsettling precedent the
mental health of anyone assigned to
scp-965 is to be strictly monitored in
case it expands its influence again
scp-965 is contained within a framed
ready to install window made up of six
panes of clear glass or other comparable
material at a size of at least 15
centimeters by 30 centimeters the window
must be kept in an environmentally
controlled storage facility k capable of
withstanding earthquakes and other
seismic activity the window must be
inspected at least once a week in order
to check the Integrity of the material
additionally at least two identical
framed windows must be stored in the
same facility in separate Chambers with
additional insulation any Lighting in
the containment chamber should be kept
at a minimum of 130 Candelas at any time
Personnel are inside with the exception
of research and experimentation though
scp-965 is currently contained the
foundation is unable to control its
movement should its current window be
destroyed therefore scp-965 is
classified as Euclid scopuphobia is the
fear of being watched or looked at by
others those suffering from this fear
will often avoid Windows terrified of
who might be standing on the other side
staring in and keeping track of
everything they do even those of us
without scopophobia might find ourselves
feeling a prickle of dread while looking
out the window at night watching for a
shadowy figure a ghastly face pressed to
the glass most of the time of course
there is no one there it's just an
overactive imagination the lingering
effect of watching one too many scary
movies but eventually your luck might
just run out one night when the world
Falls quiet and you go to close the
curtains before you go to sleep just in
case you might just feel that someone is
right there on the other side of that
thin pane of glass staring at you with
wide unblinking eyes it won't ever come
inside but it isn't going anywhere and
as long as you are where it can see you
you will never know peace again Diego
had only just found his footing when it
gave out underneath him again crashing
to the ground he threw both arms over
his head just in time to protect his
skull from the reign of Boulders that
came down past him they grazed his arms
and Jarred painfully against his muscles
but it was better than having them him
in the head without a moment to spare
Diego got straight up to his feet and
continued running back down the trail he
had been trying to follow the ground
shifted and lurched in all directions
under him threatening to throw off his
balance at any moment having lived in
Chile his whole life he had gotten used
to earthquakes but he had never been in
the center of one like this the problem
was that the trail he had been following
to get up here was disappearing fast as
the dust swirled into the air and
boulders Landing all around him he just
had to keep running in this direction
and hope for the best there weren't any
other options but suddenly he found
himself running uphill stumbling
forwards Diego tried desperately to get
his bearings he had spent the previous
three hours hiking up the mountains so
how was it that now that he had turned
around and gone back he was still going
uphill it was almost as if the ground
was changing shape beneath him as he ran
dust filled his lungs as he tried to
wipe it away from his burning eyes yes
the ground was definitely going uphill
but it felt almost as if it was lifting
itself up beneath him as if some
tectonic plates were grinding together
creating a new Mountain beneath his feet
Diego lurched unsteadily and grabbed the
nearest rock to keep his balance feeling
the ground lifting higher and higher
beneath him then all of a sudden the
cloud of dust broke and he was in fresh
air Rising ever higher into the sky the
Andes Mountains stabbed out of the
clouds all around him cutting beautiful
shapes across the Horizon he felt his
own Mountain steadily growing taller
than any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon how far would you go to prevent a
cosmic level disaster it's one thing to
save your friends and family from an
armed murderer it's another thing to
fight for your country in a world war we
can even just about imagine what it
means to fight for our planet to save
our species from climate change to save
our world from a meteorite but what
would a cosmic disaster look like a
Calamity is so Broad in scale that it
surpasses our ability to even perceive
the threat we could Point our most
advanced telescope into deep space and
look straight down the middle of it and
never know it was even there and if that
threat was not simply to the survival of
humanity or planet Earth but to the
survival of existence itself how far
would we go to prevent it what cruel and
inhumane measures would you take to have
such a threat or better yet how many
people would you kill to save the world
this debate is Raging right now as you
sit here and watch this video not among
the foundation but between two scps so
Grand scale and so advanced in nature
that the foundation has no option but to
sit and listen as the pair debate what
to do with the human race
scp-4568-1 was not difficult to discover
once it started moving in fact it was
almost impossible to ignore earthquakes
have been tearing across South America
for centuries destroying homes taking
the lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shape of our
planet itself but most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more mysterious our innocent hiker Diego
had been spending the week walking among
the Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as Diego
did that the ground Rising beneath his
feet was a new Mountain forming as the
tectonic plates clashed together but the
Staggering reality of the situation was
that he found himself hiking along the
back of
scp-4568-1 as the creature raised its
head into the air Diego saw the head of
a serpent lifting several kilometers
away from him its body stretched and
wound its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of
scp-4568-1 is hard to convey measuring
over 500 kilometers in length this
serpent is longer than most U.S states
with a 20 kilometer width standing on
the back of it quite literally feels
like standing on a mountain range for
context The Horizon at sea level is
about 4.8 kilometers away so multiply
that by 4 and you'll get a sense of just
how wide this thing is even small
movements from this SCP are enough to
trigger continent-wide earthquakes with
tremors being felt all the way around
the world upon the initial discovery of
this SCP the foundation was unable to
determine why it remains dormant for
such long periods and seems to only
awaken sporadically and for brief
periods of time that was until
scp-4568-2 was discovered it is little
wonder that the second serpent took so
long to be found its body is comprised
almost entirely of water sand algae and
steam it does not show up on Sonar scans
and is incredibly difficult to detect in
the water even visually its form is
Loosely defined while stormant with
broadly similar measurements to
scp-4568-1 this serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creatures that
swim into the scp's body find themselves
undergoing beneficial mutations crabs
grow extra Pinchers Bottom Feeders grow
larger mouths and sharks find themselves
developing heightened senses and even
extra hearts these marine animals seem
to undergo virtually no distress and are
free to exit and re-enter the scp's body
at any point initially
scp-4568-2 was believed to be the
peaceful one of the pair both serpents
seem to become active at the same time
while on land
scp-4568-1 would wreak havoc with
magnitude 7 earthquakes in major
metropolitan areas the sea Serpent's
function was less well understood
employing resonant frequencies and
vibrations this SCP was able to give its
watery body a distinct form as it rose
up from the ocean and towered above the
waves in order to maintain its shape and
control its movements this SCP employed
a huge amount of energy however the
foundation quickly observed that it was
rarely able to maintain its form for
very long as soon as the sea serpent
rose out of the water its mountainous
twin would begin to move sending Tremors
around the world that disrupted the
frequency needed for scp-4568-2
to remain animate exhausted and unable
to maintain its shape the sea serpent
would fall into another period of
dormancy gliding lazily through the
oceans but this dormances suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each SCP to mirrored bases with mirrored
teams in constant communication with one
another as soon as one team made a
discovery it was conveyed to the others
and vice versa one operating base was
set up high in the Andes Mountains
specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
withstanding earthquakes up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great SCP
several early findings stood out firstly
scp-4568-1 appeared to have a very
different internal structure from its
twin researchers initially assumed that
the creature would be largely composed
of Earth minerals and rock as its
exterior appearance suggested however
scans of its body indicated the presence
of what can only be assumed to be
artificially created components great
gears resembling Clockwork structures
and even rudimentary circuitry were
present throughout the creature's body
the function or origin of these gears
has yet to be determined especially as
there is no evident way that their
movement corresponds to the autonomy and
movement of the serpent itself the far
more striking Discovery however game
when the SCP Foundation discovered a way
to communicate with the two beasts ultra
low frequency waves capable of traveling
vast distances even light years were
discovered to be emitted from the two
serpents heads at intermittent period
the foundation had to develop some of
the largest antenna ever created to pick
up these frequencies and interpret the
data coming through them what they found
were two twins locked in a fierce debate
about the fate of humanity and the
universe itself it was only then that
the motivations of these two serpents
started to make sense in 2010 almost as
soon as the foundation was able to tap
into the frequency they were contacted
directly by
scp-4568-1 Foundation I know that you
can hear me I will not apologize for my
actions I know that I am the reason that
millions of your kind face their demise
I know your pain and I feel it too but I
shall never apologize for it I simply
ask you to listen to myself and to my
word cannot be translated you are
curious you can be patient exercised
effect and you may one day understand
and listen the foundation did efforts to
contain or destroy the two serpents were
put on the back burner instead
Foundation agents prioritize spreading
disinformation across South America and
Beyond about the source of these
earthquakes the two serpents are far too
large and far too powerful to overcome
or contain instead the foundation
prioritized the use of amnestic drugs
disinformation and the creation of
Fringe conspiracy groups to discredit
any claims of the Serpent's respective
existences meanwhile some of the most
senior leadership figures in the
foundation were and still are locked in
a fierce debate as to what to do with
the twin serpents by listening to the
communication between the two scps the
foundation discovered that
scp-4568-2 is intent on wiping out the
entire human race the only thing that
has prevented it from being able to do
so thus far has been the existence of
the other serpent every time that
scp-4568-2 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity its land-bearing twin triggers
enormous earthquakes to disrupt its
progress but why would the sea serpent
want to destroy the human race as
Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operations base
scp-4568-2 came to the observation
window to look them in the eyes as it
told them I am sure you can see it how
your world dies a little bit more every
day mostly by your own hand no you
poisoned the oceans tamed the rivers
black in the skies you do not need
angels of death to destroy your world
but there is something else I see it in
the bottom of your eyes something
Unforgettable
unconceivable ideas
colors do you think I will let you dry
the rest of the world down with
yourselves do you think I will leave
this world my world to Die In Flames
it's your world and it comes in fives
since this Revelation the foundation has
poured countless hours and resources
into trying to identify a cosmic threat
for well over a decade many of the
smartest scientists the world has to
offer have looked to the night sky
scanning for this impossible color this
shroud of Madness but to no avail some
within the foundation believe the
serpent is lying trying to make up an
excuse to justify its genocide but
information from
scp-4568-1 seems to confirm everyone's
worst fears your minds burn bread
Foundation all of humanity shines from
this rock like a candle in a dark room
it sees you an idea exists only because
something thought of it have you ever
considered how such terrible Concepts
could have been given for him what kind
of atrocious mind could even think about
it humans cannot conceive the colorless
green what if you are playing into this
creature's hands there appears to be an
underlying implication that ideas are
the source of power somehow this
colorless green this unimaginable Cosmic
threat seems to be a monstrous idea
incarnate but whose idea Humanities
there is a deep lore that the two
serpents discuss with one another one
that makes little sense even to this day
to the foundation they talk of gods and
goddesses deities of Flesh of Steel and
gears and of the fives quite what these
creatures are if they are even creatures
at all is a mystery to the foundation
researchers have not discovered a way of
communicating back with the two serpents
directly attempts to mimic their
language or transmit signals asking
questions to them have largely been
ignored instead they address you
identity and the foundation as a whole
seeming to take the view of the human
race as being a collective hive mind one
that they are evidently able to tap into
the pair seem uninterested in informing
us as to exactly what this threat is or
explaining who the gods and goddesses
are perhaps they assume we know these
things already or more likely they
believe that our Consciousness is not
yet capable of perceiving the scale and
depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the pair have names trenten is
the land serpent while remaining dormant
much of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way kaikai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains
fronten gave a short speech that served
both as encouragement and a terrible
warning of the darkness to come the
the something I Like About You from this
human about Mankind while it is easy to
just take the simplest path to just give
up there will always be some among you
who refuse this path who do the right
thing maybe not all of you are this
strong but I can see it in your methods
those so-called containment procedures
there will always be someone who stands
up against the dog even if it takes a
thousand million years to enlarge
Victorious maybe you can stop the thief
after all ideas can be killed with
better ideas even if it takes a thousand
million years
face just as quickly as I'd glimpsed it
it was gone it was cold as death and
twice as dark in here seriously I'd I'd
never been anywhere so dark it was more
than just the absence of light it was
like walking through thick black water
only able to see inches in front of my
face things move slower than they should
have every step I took further down
towards some unknowable destination the
darker and colder it got I found myself
wondering is this what dying feels like
slipping down further into nothingness
step by step through Darkness That Never
Ends it was a Stairway like Jacob's
Ladder except instead of up to heaven it
was a one-way trip straight down there
were some distant tinny whirring noise
that I couldn't quite make out the way
things sound when you're drowning I
didn't know what possibility was scarier
that the steps just went on forever and
I'd be walking until my bones turned to
dust or that something would be at the
bottom waiting for me in the dark the
paper I got the more I got the sense
that the latter was true the way you can
feel yourself being watched or sends
someone standing behind you at
evolutionary holdover for when humans
still took part in the world of
predators and prey and we were not the
Predators some part of us is just built
to know when true danger is lurking
nearby or down below patient and hungry
I could feel its malice rising up the
stairs towards me the way people in a
skyscraper Catching Fire can feel the
heat coming up from below and no it's
already too late for them for the first
time my eyes came into focus and I made
something out in the distance when I
realized what it was and worse how
strikingly familiar it was all I could
do was scream that's when I woke up
drenched in sweating and relieved to see
the darkness of the stairway replaced by
Bright Morning lights shining in through
my bedroom window my brother Steve was
standing there with a concerned look on
his face he told me I'd been screaming
in my sleep and asked me if I'd been
having that dream again it made me feel
like an idiot but I had to nod and tell
him yes it was the same one this weird
nightmare I've been having day after day
and despite it almost always being the
same thing it somehow never got any less
frightening there was no way to even
describe the profound sense of dread I
felt walking down those stairs and
finally seeing what was waiting for me
below even though I could never actually
remember what it was upon waking Steve
told me not to worry about it and toss
some clothes onto my bed he assured me
that it was probably just final stress
seeing as we were a mere few months from
graduating I needed to be up in Adam
today we were touring one of our first
choice colleges my brother and I had
always been close even if we hadn't been
fraternal twins I think we still would
have been best friends all through
elementary middle and high school we
were practically joined at the hip so it
only made sense that when we were
getting close to graduation we wanted to
go to the same College we'd be friends
to the end until we were old men on the
porch and rocking chair years it so
happened that we were together in the
end just not in the way I'd hoped the
two of us arrived to check out the
potential College a few hours later it
was a nice day out the brightness of the
sky and the Lush Greenery across campus
quickly banished the bitter memories of
that bad dream High School hadn't
exactly been a picnic for me I'm the
nervous type if you couldn't already
tell Steve who was the more outgoing and
confident one always looked out for me
he'd always been there whenever I was
dealing with bullies or academic stress
but at College I felt like I could
reinvent myself and become the kind of
person I'd always wanted to be as we
hopped from building to building across
the tour checking out the different
facilities and attending a few sample
lectures and seminars I was only
becoming more confident that college
would be the place for me to finally
Bloom it was perfect for me but despite
this college being exactly what I'd
wanted in terms of lifestyle and
academic Pursuits there was a certain
stain on its reputation if any
University is around long enough for any
building at all for that matter weird
incidents are bound to accumulate some
places have ghost or Cryptid sightings
this college had disappearances not just
one or two six different students and
one janitor had disappeared from the
campus the people had nothing in common
except for the fact that they frequented
the college ages races genders and
Majors varied across all the missing
people and none of them had known each
other no notes were given no clues
discovered no remains ever found a
number of the cases are even still open
today it's a frightening thought that
people can just drop off the face of the
Earth like that and never be found there
are over half a million missing person
cases in the United States back in 2020
alone it's more common than you think
still I comforted myself with the
knowledge that thousands of new students
came in and out of the college every
year and only a handful of
disappearances what were the chances
that something bad would ever happen to
me though to be fair every person who
actually did disappear in their last
moment's thought what are the chances
something like this would happen to me
too we were several hours into the tour
when the coffee Steve had on the way
over finally caught up with him he
needed to go bad so we asked our tour
guide whether there was a bathroom
anywhere around here she told him that
he could find one pretty easily on the
ground floor of any Administrative
Building nearby in the meantime we'd be
making our way over to lecture hall 2B
so he could simply catch up with us
there once he was done Steve left and I
didn't think anything of it at the time
I was too wrapped up in the tour it was
only half an hour later when we were
finishing up and preparing to leave
lecture hall 2B and his absence from the
group suddenly became a lot more
noticeable I started feeling nervous
he'd just gone to the bathroom what
could be taking so long I ran through
all the more rational explanations in my
head maybe there was a long line maybe
the bathroom was out of order when he
got there and he needed to find another
one maybe he got a little lost on the
way there maybe he got a little lost on
the way back there were so many
perfectly rational reasons he wasn't
with us right now but as the minutes
dragged done each one felt a little less
likely and a dark pit of dread began to
form in my stomach it wasn't long before
I alerted the tour guide naturally she
tried to calm me down saying How likely
it is that he'd just gotten lost Steve
was a smart kid he was thinking of going
to this college after all so he must be
smart it was a smattering of laughter
from the tour group still she put the
word out to her fellow staff members and
the search began despite trying my best
to avoid panicking the stats about all
those disappearances just kept flashing
through my mind what if we were the
Unlucky ones what if Steve had actually
disappeared just like the others and I'd
never see him again as the hours marched
on and he still wasn't found that was
all I could think about I I didn't want
to lose him I tried calling his cell
phone and texting him countless times
but got no response you can only imagine
my relief when I suddenly got a call
from him though when I heard the content
of the call that relief quickly
disappeared the reception was patchy and
his voice had a strange Echo to it like
he was somewhere deep in cavernous there
was this other noise in the background
too this strange tinny wine that felt
oddly familiar I only caught a few words
from him before the call cut out the
door stay away it keeps going something
down here don't come looking oh God if I
was scared before I was utterly
mortified now I couldn't just leave my
brother in a situation like this no
matter what he told me to do I had to
find him somehow I just had to nobody
else seemed to take it seriously but I
somehow knew he was in the most terrible
danger that's when I decided to head to
the one place I believed he would be the
administrative building it was such an
unremarkable little building hardly the
kind of place where you'd expect some
terrible secret to be hiding but
dangerous things often hide in plain
sight things like the door it was one of
those things from Steve's message that
had stuck in my head the door call it
Instinct call it intuition call it blind
dumb luck but when I was standing in
front of an average looking door in that
unremarkable Administrative Building I
knew I was staring at the exact door
that my brother had been talking about
it radiated bad vibes Dark Energy was
practically humming off of it but I
wouldn't let that stop me perhaps I was
stupid going in without help well it's
easy to criticize from the safety of
your home it's worth remembering we do
silly things when we're afraid and I
mean this was my brother we're talking
about here no one in the world was more
important to me than him no one the
second I entered the room Beyond the
Door something changed it was like
stepping into another world entirely the
air was thick and oppressive the floor
below me and the walls around me were
ungodly cold but most remarkable of all
was the dark even my phone's flashlight
at full power barely made a dent I don't
think I'd ever seen anything so truly
impenetrably dark outside of a certain
nightmare anyway that was when I finally
realized where I was standing at the top
of the stairs those stairs the stairs
that had been haunting my rest less
sleep a single winding stairwell down
into the void every part of me wanted to
run and scream and hide but I couldn't I
knew that if it were me trapped down
there Steve wouldn't have hesitated he
would have charged down there and helped
me now I had to do the same for him
after all we all know that in real life
there's no such thing as monsters and
how deep could a staircase really go
anyway that question was soon put to the
test as I descended down into the pit I
counted 13 steps each time before
reaching a small platform there were
strange markings and scratches on the
wall the further I descended every
footstep I took echoed on and on and on
I must have been walking for a solid 15
minutes traveling and possibly deep when
I finally heard something else I called
out Steve's name but quickly realized it
wasn't him it was a little girl weeping
a few hundred feet below I couldn't tell
if she was afraid in pain or both but
hearing it put ice in my veins what the
hell was going on down there had whoever
taken her her taking Steve to what
exactly was I dealing with these were
the questions racing through my mind as
I got deeper and deeper into the belly
of the Beast time ceased to matter as
the flights went on and on beneath me
even descending into deeper colder
Darkness I was literally walking into my
own nightmare but seeing as the only
alternative was leaving my brother to
die down here I couldn't do anything
else I was down countless flights of
stairs when I finally saw him it was a
distant pale Speck dithering and afraid
he was a full flight down from me I was
so happy to see him that at first I
didn't even notice anything was wrong as
I got closer I began to realize that
this wasn't the Steve I knew the dread
crept into me spreading through every
cell like a virus I finally knew why I
recognized it it was the thing for my
dreams the monster whose appearance
always brought those terrible nightmares
to an end but what did it mean to see it
in real life it was Steve's face but it
seemed larger and deathly pale I froze
and as the face Drew closer to me I
realized it had no irises no pupils no
nostrils and no mouth it wasn't my
brother it looked like a terrible
death-like mask modeled after him I
tried to scream as it appeared right in
front of me just as I had in my dreams
but it was too late long gnarled fingers
curled around my torso and crushed my
ribs it was a pain more intense than I
thought possible and soon even my vision
went black as I was dragged down to the
darkness below the last thought on my
mind was Steve I'm so sorry I couldn't
save you I couldn't even save myself
violent chaos unfolds across the
shoreline huge fleshy tendrils Slither
out of the water grabbing people who try
to flee and drag them into the depths as
giant harpoons made of bone whiz across
the beach cutting down unfortunate
sunbathers and droves it is a terrifying
Massacre but you'd never in a million
years be able to guess its source on
April 10th 2010 something strange began
to happen in the three Portland
now the anomalous extra-dimensional
city-state that overlaps with the
locations of Portland Oregon Portland
Maine and the Isle of Portland is no
stranger to unusual occurrences so it
took the population a little while to
notice that something was happening but
for some unknown reason sailboats and
motorboats were beginning to vanish from
the city the disappearances occurred
overnight when there was no one around
to witness them but slowly the citizens
began to notice that their friends and
family members were going out in their
watercrafts and never returning home by
April 15th the civilians were becoming
noticeably concerned fearing the worst
on April 16th their worst fears were
confirmed when two local coasts on
karachnid and Greg Moore went for a
nighttime stroll along the harbor they
heard a sudden commotion and rushed to
the scene of the disturbance they
arrived just in time to see a living
individual being dragged into the watery
depths by a large rain-like tendril
Ahmed asked Greg to wait on land while
he ventured out into the water to look
for the victim unfortunately Ahmed never
came back and Greg took his story to the
three Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local
man-eating clam populace to migrate the
FBI unusual incidence unit mounted a
formal investigation on the morning of
April 17th all the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
what not been returned along with them
on April 19th uiu agents dove into the
harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 21st
the threat that had been preying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11 19 am 17 teen
boats moved away from the docks on their
own drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in or out civilians watched in
shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes growing thick
masses of scales on their surfaces
sprouting Harpoon guns that fired bony
projectiles and slashing veiny tendrils
at anyone within reach the citizens
began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous boats but they were too slow
to evade the attacks and the boat
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of fleshy boats closed in
around the shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to drag itself along the shore
and into the more populous part of town
it grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert izat
a noted member of the Church of the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach izat a city security Golem
interfered sadly though the Golem put up
a valiant fight the anomaly was able to
destroy it by Falling onto it again and
again until the Golem was no longer able
to get back up there are few creatures
that would survive having a boat drop
itself on top of them repeatedly and
sadly the security Golem was not one of
them with the Golem out of the way the
boat continued to drag itself through
the streets wildly crashing through the
side of a local restaurant where its
owner an entity known as the gruel was
in the middle of a busy brunch service
at the site of the invading watercraft
the gruels set down his picture of
bottomless mimosas wiped his hands on
his apron and grabbed his trusty
dual-wield swords from underneath the
counter he kept them there in case
someone attempted to dine and dash but
he figured they would do just fine
against a blood-drinking tugboat while
the gruel kept the tugboat busy uiu
forces were able to break through the
barricade of boats for a brief period of
time allowing more security Golems to
enter the area as well as allowing more
citizens to escape unfortunately this
little victory was short-lived as
further unforeseen Horrors drudged
themselves up from the deep the
reanimated corpses of various species
native to the harbor began to crawl out
of the water surrounding the gruel and
allowing the tugboat to escape the fight
as it made its way back to the harbor
every boat it passed attempted to toss
bodies onto the tugboat covering it in
fresh blood slowly but surely really the
damage to the tugboat began to repair
itself once the boat had regained its
strength it set its sights on a
previously untouched cargo ship and
observing uiu officer determined that
the boat was somehow attempting to
convert the cargo ship to transform it
into another one of its fleshy allies
but before the transformation could take
place a cargo crate broke open spilling
over 1 000 hardtack crackers suddenly
the tugboat stopped everything that it
was doing it took one tendril and began
to count each individual cracker that
had Spilled Out while the tugboat was
distracted with its task a citizen
offered the uiu use of their rare Metals
Cannonball collection in the fight to
apprehend the aggressive boat one
particular Cannonball made from electrum
was able to puncture the whole of one of
the infected ships rendering it
motionless they were related to have
found a weapon that worked against these
boats while the tugboat continued to
count the remaining townspeople gathered
all of the electrum they could find and
began to fight back against the boats
One By One The Boat sank and all the
while the tugboat continued to count in
the meantime uiu officers managed to
free the gruel from his zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the gruel had a score
to settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the girl barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the
girl then threw the tugboat out of the
water and continued The Savage beating
before preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat kareemed through the air
colliding with a portal that had trans
exported it to the Isle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the gruel and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
and given the designation of
scp-6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat
scp-6426 is a ketter-class Sapient
hostile entity that in an inactive State
Bears the appearance of a harbor Tugboat
in a constant state of rust and
degradation any blood or organs
containing blood that come into contact
with the boat will be absorbed through
the metal causing the degradation to
visibly prove as a result the most
effective blood appears to come from
humans cetaceans and a few specific
species of solutions The Entity does not
only use the absorbed blood to improve
its appearance but is also capable of
using it to create organic additions to
its body including the vein-like
tendrils spotted in the three Portlands
Cognito hazardous eyes attached to
bending eye stalks Harpoon guns and
cannons capable of firing ammunition
made from anomalous species of barnacles
these Barnacles are capable of
reanimating dead tissue on contact and
scp-6426 frequently uses them to create
instances of
scp-6426-c masses of reanimated tissue
that the boat uses to Aid in its attacks
or self-defense
scp-6426 uses its tendrils to grab prey
and drag them towards itself but the
tendrils serve an additional purpose as
well each of the tendrils has a mouth on
the tip similar in structure to to that
of the North American medicinal leech
when the tendril has made contact with
its prey the mouth will then bite into
the spinal column of the creature
causing its brain function to cease as
its canines grow long and Hollow hard
scales form on their skin and their
muscle mass and bone density increase
once they've been transformed in this
way organisms taken by a cp6426 are
designated
scp-6426-a these instances are used to
the entity's advantage helping it to
extract blood from victims at a distance
as well as providing an additional line
of defense and offense in the event that
scp-6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use
scp-6426-a to convert the vehicle into
an instance of
scp-6426-b these converted boats are
similar to
scp-6426 and are able to function on
their own however they are unable to
produce their own eye stocks or cannons
a unable to create
scp-6426-a instances and do not appear
to be as intelligent as their creator in
the early days of its containment the
exact nature of the anomaly's
intelligence was the subject of debate
amongst the research staff however on
one specific occasion the foundation was
able to establish a line of direct
communication with
scp-6426 and conduct the first and so
far the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and use the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that scp-6426
responded to interview questions using
the voice of one of its victims Junior
researcher sajad Williamson in spite of
his protests was selected to conduct the
interview his fellow staff members
refused to take no for an answer and as
the newest hire the unpleasant job fell
on his shoulders much to everyone's
surprise the anomaly began the
conversation rather politely saying I am
so sorry I thought you were the
self-righteous lunatics from the church
I apologize profusely for any trouble I
may have caused and I want to point out
I a fully support your mission yes our
first line of defense against the
undersea Menace I am more than willing
to punch sharks selections yes right
how rude of me yes Dr Williamson's first
question concerned
scp-6426 apparent intended victim back
in three Portlands Albert is at
scp-6426 responded Albert his first name
is really Albert well what other
relationship is there to say besides the
Hunter and the hunted Admiral izat is a
ruthless Man known for terrorizing and
slaughtering people like me he was
leading a search party of those barbaric
notophiles intending to gut me like a
seal what do you mean people like you Dr
Williamson inquired free thinkers of
course people who are unafraid to break
from the mold to carve their own path in
life instead of following the
predetermined route set by that ignorant
check valve the church is built upon the
foundation of lies no one's really a
petty officer on this ship would all
just cabin boys stumbling around in the
dark as we followed the commands of an
off-hand cob
[Laughter]
if you want real power real Freedom all
you have to do is listen for the call of
the Beast open the porthole and he'll
squeeze you right through
Dr Williamson feeling rather in over his
head attempted to convince one of his
colleagues to take over when he refused
however Dr Williamson continued uh could
you explicate your activities within the
harbor and how you arrive there well
after I got the boat swans off my trail
I found a cave to hide them I was forced
to hide them yes forced to hide deep in
the cave which turned out to be a tunnel
surprisingly the tunnel led to some
Coastal Community where I took Refuge
licking my wounds in the safety of the
depths as ozelot stuck the surface I
spent my time preparing Gathering the
strength necessary to face them once
more until I was ambushed assaulted
within my
I fought for my life as I was forced out
into the open and descended upon by a
manner of monsters and freaks of this
orchestrated by that scumbag ISAT I was
beaten within an inch of my life before
I'm not quite sure what happened after
that I believe I was not unconscious
you'll have to Illuminate Me on how I
came to be in your custody at this point
the interview began to Veer in an odd
Direction the boat expressed confusion
about the nature of Williamson's
questions specifically how little they
related to the subject of sharks and
punching them it was at this point that
the site director sought guidance from
the multi-u Department a researcher
there informed Williamson about the
confusion
scp-6426 had mistaken the SCP Foundation
for another organization the shark
punching Center Dr Williamson resumed
the interview prepared to play along and
keep the boat comfortable unfortunately
Williamson was a terrible liar yes we
are the shark punching Center we will
determine if you are a suitable
candidate to carry out the mission to
search punch and contain ship
I mean Solutions this verbal misstep
caused scp-6426 to become suspicious
after a moment it pieced together the
truth and began to throw itself against
the wall in a desperate attempt to
escape it was apprehended by security
guards who impaled it with a naval RAM
and returned the watercraft to its
containment cell the exact reason for
its apparent fear and hatred of the
foundation is currently unknown and the
boat has made no attempt to speak since
currently
scp-6426 is kept in a 39 meter by 39
meter by 50 meter containment chamber
beneath the chamber there is an
artificial lava tube the tugboat has a
naval Ram through its Hull and engine
holding it in place this Ram is checked
daily for signs of degradation as it is
the primary force keeping the anomaly
immobile if the ram is ever removed or
damaged somehow a Fail-Safe system will
activate releasing 100 hardtack crackers
and two pieces of electrum into the
containment chamber this is intended to
keep the tugboat occupied until the
naval Rod can be replaced if for some
reason the naval Rod fails and the boat
runs out of hardtack to count while
there will be nowhere on water or land
that we can hide ask anyone that has
been through it and they'll all tell you
the same the moving home is maybe one of
the most stressful things that a normal
person can ever experience it's a
logistical nightmare right from the
start the moment you talk to a realtor
about being interested in selling your
current house and buying another
everything goes downhill from there
after that moment an avalanche of things
comes hurtling towards you finding a
place you like making an offer letting
people look around your house waiting
for them to make a counteroffer
exchanging contracts and that's before
you even have thought about packing and
as Milo had learned doing all of that on
your own only makes the stress of moving
feel all the more potent but he had
finally made it after a constant back
and forth with his realtor the time had
come for him to pack up all of his
worldly possession and relocate to a
brand new place to call home he had felt
it was long overdue for him to get a
change of scenery and luckily just the
right place had come onto the market to
answer that call it was a pretty big
house bigger than Milo's previous home
but considerably cheaper in fact he
thought it had been significantly
undervalued the house had an almost
Victorian era feel to it all beautifully
carved and varnished Woodwork and creaky
old floorboards but in more of an
elegant refined sort of way rather than
a creepier one that's not to say Milo's
new place wasn't without its more
unsettling elements aside from being big
spacious and easy to imagine as being
haunted the creepiest thing about the
house aside from its frighteningly low
price was the story of what happened to
the previous owners obviously you know
that legally we have to disclose whether
or not anyone died on this property the
realtor had explained wearing a force
grin as she showed Milo around the house
hearing that sentence he could feel the
hairs on the back of his neck stand up
someone died here he asked in disbelief
no no no no of course not sir the
realtor instantly walked back her
statement Less in an effort to ease her
clients nerves but more to ensure that
she still closed the deal and earned her
commission bonus then why the hell would
you start a sentence like that Milo
asked we just have to give full
disclosure but I assure you the previous
residents didn't die on the grounds of
this house she gave that fake smile
again it was pretty ineffectual at
reassuring him so what happened to the
last owner well it's a bit of a mystery
to be honest a local Legend if you like
but hey that gives the place more flavor
hearing some spooky history right think
of what a conversation starter that will
be the realtor ended her sentence with a
forced snorting laugh but rained it back
in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the Shaw's they were apparently
very quiet reclusive kept to themselves
a lot I'm sure you know the type Milo
couldn't help but notice she shot him a
look as she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay and no one had
any bad mishaps in the house you know
how old folks can be such a worry when
they get to that age yeah totally Milo
interjected where the realtor was
stalling he repeated so what actually
happened to them well that's the thing
she Shrugged Nobody Knows the full story
one day the neighbors across the street
noticed they hadn't seen Mr and Mrs Shaw
for quite a while so naturally they came
on over here to see if they were in and
the last thing they wanted was to assume
everything was hunky-dory here I mean
hey better save them sorry right but
once they got inside they couldn't find
either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were just
gone vanish Without a Trace most people
on the street thought they had just sold
the place kept it quiet and moved away
retired to somewhere nice and exotic Oh
well that sounds nice I suppose Milo
replied relieved to hear that there
hadn't been any brutal unsolved murders
in the house and that it most likely
wasn't haunted that's just what the
neighbors think anyway the realtor
continued of course they hadn't sold the
house they just left it when my firm
came in to repossess the place it had
all their belongings in it some might
even still be laying around here anyway
did you want to have a look at that
contract well strictly speaking Milo was
the only human living in his new house
he was never fully alone he had arrived
with his two closest friends a pair of
pets he had adopted while living in his
old house one was a hamster by the name
of donut named after his round little
body and the golden brown shade of his
fur had reminded Milo of the glazed
sugary baked treat the other was Pixel a
bearded dragon with a pattern on his
scales that resembled some kind of
mosaic art the first order of business
Milo had decided was before even
unpacking he needed to make sure his
scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the realtor
had said the Shah still had some of
their possessions left lying around the
place most of it was useless to Milo old
man's clothes are a set of knitting
needles and rolls of colorful thread it
was those particular clues that seemed
to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot of free time
on her hands and maybe took up knitting
as a hobby during retirement of course
the bigger clue was the huge handmade
blanket that Milo found draped over some
of the remaining boxes in the Attic he
wasn't exactly well versed in knitwear
but he could appreciate the craft behind
behind this soft blanket it clearly had
a lot of time and effort put into making
it painstakingly knitting each and every
individual thread looping it around a
pair of Steel needles and eventually
after hours of wearing out shaking bony
fingers produce something that actually
looked quite nice even though the idea
of sitting and knitting a blanket might
have been one of the most boring uses of
time Milo could imagine he still had to
admit he was surprised that the Shaws
had left this particular piece of
bedding behind it seemed like it would
be pretty comfy to sleep under it might
help keep a person warm at night now
that the colder seasons were approaching
what's more was that the blanket was
clean almost like it had been freshly
washed there was no old person smell on
it no dirt or discoloration not a stain
and it hadn't even accumulated any dust
in its fibers in fact he noticed that
there was hardly any dust at all up in
the attic despite the house being empty
for so long he assumed the Realtors had
hired someone as a care caretaker while
they found a buyer for the place and
they had kept the place clean after all
what other conclusion could they have
possibly drawn it's not as if something
had eaten all the dust that would be
absurd he'd have a sort through of the
Shaw's leftovers later maybe sell some
of it off at a local yard sale or give
it to a thrift store but that blanket
might come in handy when it started
snowing so Milo had half a mind to keep
it now part of what makes moving home
such a stressful life experience isn't
just all the logistical and
administrative parts of the process it's
only made worse by the fact that it
takes forever to move into a new house
fully that's the part everyone always
forgets about the months after a move
when you're forced to live amongst
towers of cardboard boxes all your
worldly possessions buried deep within
them and you can never remember which
crate anything is in when you urgently
need it so realizing it would take him
much longer to unpack all of his things
Milo set about making sure he had
everything that that donut and pixel
would need already to hand the latter of
his two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day donut on the other hand was much
more of a free spirit the tiny brown
hamster physically could not stay still
and most days seem to be filled with
more energy than Milo was as a result he
let the little guy roll about inside a
little plastic ball all day long until
his little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
around the house it didn't take him long
to realize however that the Realtors had
pulled a bit of a fast one on him
despite the absolute steal of a price
that Milo had been offered it quickly
became clear that the unknown Aid of the
previous residence wasn't the only
detail about the house that had been
conveniently kept hidden the place was
in dire need of repair with a lot of the
old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams to
make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water which would
quickly become an even bigger problem
when the weather started to get colder
then to top off the trifecta of
unforeseen issues and teething problems
with his new place Milo couldn't sleep
it was to be expected after all the
house was old worn out and had
definitely seen better days there were
bound to be a few noises the odd Creek
coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs the tapping
of branches against Windows blowing in
the wind outside but for some reason
every audible disturbance that emanated
from some hidden corner of the building
only seemed to get a thousand times
louder when the sun went down at night
time every squeaky floorboard or random
noise of the house settling was nearly
deafening enough to pull Milo right out
of what little Restless sleep he was
getting the worst part about it was
though he couldn't help it it made him
feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shahs showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at night Milo was seeing
the old couple in every bad dream he had
both their faces were locked in those
same still frozen EXP expressions of
contempt as they try to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail in the coffin
that made Milo realize he needed to look
at other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
Milo took one look at the little brown
furred hamster than the crates that
still littered the place grabbing the
leftover items that the shods had
forgotten to take with them before they
vanished Milo moved those boxes out into
the shed he knew he was probably
reaching that it was hard likely to make
even the slightest difference to his
sleeping but maybe keeping their stuff
away from him would keep the old couple
out of his head the only thing he kept
in the house was the blanket there was
no use letting it go to waste especially
knowing that the boiler was on the blink
and it would be cold soon he rolled it
up and left it on his bed leaving his
more mobile pet in the same room before
heading out to see the doctor when Milo
got back a bottle of prescription
sleeping pills in his pocket he couldn't
help but notice his room seemed
different the blanket looked like it had
fallen off the bed and onto the floor
for one but more worryingly Donuts
plastic travel ball had been split open
laying in pieces on the ground with its
furry little occupant nowhere to be seen
over the next few hours Milo searched
every corner of the house calling out to
his hamster trying to lure it back with
more morsels of food but donut didn't
seem to be anywhere he wasn't even
underneath the knitted blanket still
there was no sign as worry set in Milo
Hurley checked pixel's cage to see if he
was gone too but the lizard was relaxing
as lethargic as ever completely unfazed
by what was going on it certainly seemed
that when it rained it really record in
this new house just as he was searching
for his missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it finally giving out after
God knows how many years it had been
installed for the house is boiler burst
spending the afternoon into the evening
failing to track down one of his Missing
Pets and stopping the huge iron cast
boiler from flooding the basement wasn't
exactly what Milo had in mind for fun
activities to do when he got home going
to bed frustrated made it as hard to
sleep as all the nightly cacophony of
creaking floorboards and branches raking
against the windows he tapped out two of
the pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a swig of cold water
before laying back in bed as night had
fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his breath forming clouds in front of
his face he reached for the knitted
blanket and threw it over himself
curling up underneath it to try and
provide an extra layer of warmth to
protect himself from the gnawing cold
the pills did as they were meant to
helping Milo to quickly sleep into a
much deeper sleep than he had
experienced in a while although it
didn't seem to help the nightmares Mr
and Mrs Shaw came back again this time
they had Milo's arms and legs tied up
with their matching disapproving faces
the elderly couple threw something over
their helpless victim and tried to
smother him to death for a dream it felt
so intense so real Milo could feel a
heavy weight on top of his body as he
slept in fact it felt like it was all
around him engulfing and crushing the
life out of him from all sides but it
was the feeling of something wet against
his arm the sensation of liquid against
his skin and the numbness where his
hands should be were what finally pulled
him out of the dream and into the night
mare through the dark and his cloudy
vision Milo could see a wide gaping moth
filled with teeth the feeling of being
crushed was still surrounding him and
despite kicking his legs and trying to
free himself from confinement it didn't
stop squeezing him tighter his Panic was
already making it harder to catch his
breath but now he could barely fill his
lungs enough to scream for help not that
anyone was around to hear him but it was
the sight of his arm that chilled Milo's
blood it wasn't there anymore part of it
just above the elbow was just gone his
hand fingers every internal bone and
muscle had been reduced to a bloody mess
a slurry of red melting and coming apart
it was runny little more than a liquid
resembling the consistency of sand when
it's under water and becomes sludge most
of his flesh was liquefied going further
up his arm and as the blanket pulled its
prey into its mouth until Milo was no
more not a trace of him left just like
the previous owners little did Milo or
the Shaws and donut let before him know
but he'd been the victim of a creature
that was part of a rather unique species
while they will often vary in size shape
pattern and other aspects of their
appearance
scp-799 always seemed to be ordinary
items of knitted bedware at least at
first they retain heat like a normal
blanket would and are soft to the touch
and for the most part don't seem
directly harmful and usually they aren't
scp-799s are incapable of much movement
instead laying still a lot of time not
unlike a certain bearded dragon that
just lost its owner they also don't seem
to require much in the way of food
extracting with little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter and dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an scp-799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
well they they possess this biological
trait themselves
scp-799 don't seem to regard
cold-blooded animals to be the source of
food in fact they don't even seem to be
able to detect other creatures with cold
blood such as reptiles instead
scp-799 will metamorphose into a more
predatory form in order to consume any
warm-blooded mammal or human being it
encounters transforming its feeding
orifices and digestive tract into a
singular mouth lined with several rolls
of sharp pointed teeth from there it
will wrap up the largest warm-blooded
animal it can find whether that be a
hamster or a grown man and will tear off
parts of its prey reducing them to
little more than a thin slurry as it
digests their body mass to feed itself
so if you move into a new house and come
across an old knitted blanket maybe
consider throwing it out if you want to
live the diver screams A Silent Scream
as the giant Squid's beak digs into his
skin
its many grasping tentacles grabbing him
and holding him in place nearby his
fellow divers are driven half mad with
Terror as they see mysterious figures
floating towards them through the Merc
and strange Russian voices speaking in
their heads nobody can help them they're
down too deep too consumed by the
darkness and the pressure of the sea
they're now at the mercy of whatever is
inside the submarine beginning in the
1940s with the dawn of nuclear weapons
the American government conducting the
world's first atomic weapons test and
the Soviet Union responding in kind with
nuclear testing of their own the two
Powers entered an arms race fueled by
rivalry and a thirst to prove their
strength on the world stage What
followed were Decades of Staggering
technological advancements as each
Nation tried to outdo and intimidate the
other the Soviet Union crossed into the
cold reaches of outer space deploying
the satellite Sputnik the United States
responded with the founding of NASA
tensions reached a fever pitch during
the Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962 as
United States citizens feared they were
teetering on the brink of nuclear war in
July of 1968 the Soviet Union the United
Kingdom and the United States came
together to sign the treaty on the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons
agreeing to abandon their pursuit of
increasing nuclear power and turn their
focus to disarmament but several months
before the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as
scp-741
scp-741 is the underwater wreckage of a
Soviet submarine that sank in March of
1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999. the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under usual circumstances which
attracted the attention of the United
States government in an attempt to learn
more about the submarine the US
government launch project redacted which
attempted to recover the vessel from the
ocean in the early 1970s they managed to
recover a few pieces of the vessel
though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the U.S
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible Euclid or
ketterclass anomaly in the rack at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hull was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no no
members of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seemed to have left something
behind whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a manned Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described an incident report
1741-a divers a-26 through a30 embarked
from the Icebreaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surrounding the wreckage as the
group of divers approached the submarine
they could feel the shift in the water
around them the oppressive feeling of
abnormally increasing pressure bearing
down and threatening to crush them if
their specialized diving equipment were
to fail they knew that that would be it
and the command would have to come and
fish their corpses out of the water or
even worse they would vanish entirely
meeting the same mysterious fate as the
crew of that doomed submarine but they
couldn't fixate on that they had a job
to do at first glance the wreckage
appeared undisturbed unchanged since the
previous inspection still they needed to
take a closer look to be sure as the
team got closer to the vessel a30 was
startled by the side of movement from
within the wreckage spotting motion
through one of the holes in the
structure as something passed by he
pointed it out to his colleagues but
they dismissed it as likely a giant
isopod or spider crab which were
crawling all over the surrounding area
a30 laughed off his jumpiness agreed
that they were probably right and
continued the exploration as planned
control authorize the divers to proceed
to the next step and a29 activated sonar
and lights moving toward the starboard
side breach there a faint glowing caught
his eye the glow resembled that of
radioactive material but when the team
checked the radiation levels in the area
they remained stable whatever the source
of the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
can you hear me the voice was muffled
and though could be heard over their
communication channels it emanated from
somewhere in the wreckage deep deep
underwater as a29 watched a glowing
shape emerged from the darkness it was
only an outline the suggestion of a
silhouette but the shape was undeniably
familiar it looked like a person the
other divers quickly noted the operation
2 and began to panic some checked their
nitrogen levels believing it to be be
some sort of nitrogen Narcosis While
others pointed out that they couldn't
all be suffering from nitrogen Narcosis
at the same time the unknown voice
continued speaking saying if me it is
getting hard to breathe the divers
debated what to do next questioning
whether what they were seeing was even
real when all at once the humanoid
figure vanished from sight the divers
attempted to shake off the startling
encounter and they resumed their duties
the investigation proceeding as normal
after a few moments of uneventful work
another Interruption presented itself in
the form of a five meter long squid
swimming around the wreckage its
presence startled the divers at first
particularly those closest to the animal
but the others encouraged them to ignore
it citing the fact that there are no
records of these squid attacking humans
so they did continuing their work as the
squid circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat he
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but but the side of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of scp-714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process a squid are not
known to attack humans unprovoked this
Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of scp-741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the rack with a
radius of approximately 250 meters
starting around the center of the
submarine the pressure in this area is
much greater than it should be given the
depth of the waters there this unusually
high pressure makes sonar analysis
extremely difficult as well as
threatening the safety of any divers in
the vicinity of the rack the few records
that the foundation has managed to
obtain from the Russian and U.S
government indicate that the submarine
was being used to transport some sort of
secret cargo though the specifics of
this cargo are still unknown there is
reason to believe that it differed from
any type of nuclear or chemical Weaponry
on a date redacted from official files
the scps basisti was patrolling the area
around scp-741 when its sonar detected
some unknown entity approaching scp-741
from the south at a pace of 46 knots the
crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
basisti attempted to reach the contact
via sonobui drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an underseen missile launch
and vasisti responded with the utmost
urgency the ship broke away from its
original area and fired a type 53
torpedo at the underwater threat 15
seconds after the basisti launched its
torpedo missiles of an unidentified
configuration were seen breaking the
water flying at a height of 1.8 meters
and a velocity of 0.92 Mach the missiles
did not emit any detectable radar nor
did they respond to any launch chaff or
flares from the basisti both of the
missiles were engaged by basisti's 3kn5
kinsol surface-to-air missiles and cash
stand Point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 meters and 210 meters
from Impact respectively after the
missiles were neutralized the Hostile
vessel could be heard engaging in
evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward scp-741 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
of undersea retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident
1741-c the sonar recordings from the
scps specisti during incident
1741-c were taken for further analysis
by the research team the in-depth review
revealed anomalous acoustic signatures
that did not match up with any known
forms of propulsion including Magneto
hydrodynamic Drive currently the nature
of the unidentified attacker remains a
mystery and it has not been attributed
to any particular government or
organization following the incident
involving the scps basisti an American
intelligence agent reached out to the
foundation offering further insight into
the secretive government programs
looking into
scp-741 he agreed to sit for an
interview with a foundation researcher
assigned to the project on the condition
that is identity remain protected the
SCP researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the U.S
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too now the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of the crewmen were buried
Just Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes in a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand load
in the thing just no bodies left when I
first looked into all this I had no clue
what the hell had gone on down there but
I started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts at vile preparent a spies
wind up owning each other favors after a
while and they denied it vehemently not
your usual cover-up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted no
part of it sounded like he was gonna
puke when I mentioned redacted doctor do
you have any idea what it takes to make
a bioweapons researcher sick now that
wasn't what really bugged me though what
really kept me awake at night was the
KGB file that fell into our hands they
mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the U.S of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too loaning you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that scp-741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships as CPS basisti and
krasno yarsk has been selected for this
purpose if any unauthorized activity
occurs in the area surrounding scp-741
nuclear and conventional missiles may be
deployed any movement of scp-741 is
grounds for an immediate Nuclear Strike
whatever Secrets as CP 741 holds
whatever it was transporting that was
even more of an uncontrollable threat
than nuclear warfare they're better left
alone down there at the bottom of the
sea when the sun rose on that fateful
day Jerry marks had been one of the
lucky ones he worked in a mine deep
underground at the edge of a small town
in the rural United States which meant
he didn't see what happened when day
broke when the light of the sun ravaged
the Earth the first Jerry heard about it
was when his son Kyle came racing into
the mine frantically tapping his dad's
shoulder to get his attention he'd run
all the way from their tiny Homestead
under a fireproof blanket thick and long
enough to block the sunlight from
touching any part of Kyle's skin his
older sister his daughter Carly hadn't
been so lucky caught by the Light her
body had turned to the consistency of
warm candle wax melting into a form that
barely resembled human anymore Jerry had
been one of a handful of others working
late in the mines that day a few thought
that young Kyle had made the whole story
up and ventured up to the surface and
into the light only to make the same
Twisted Fate the light morphed their
bodies into monstrosities anyone in the
small rural community becoming an
amorphous mass of human flesh eventually
those that stayed behind in the mine
heard the voices of their loved ones
their wives husbands children all
calling out to them from outside they
promised that nothing was wrong that it
was a lovely sunny day outside and the
Mine Workers should clock out to come
and enjoy it more of them left reassured
by hearing their families that all was
well and once more none of them were
seen again only Jerry and Kyle were left
and it stayed that way for several
months the father and son had to adapt
to life underground only leaving the
mind to forage for food and only while
wearing thick dirty mining overalls
making sure not a single millimeter of
skin was on display if the sunlight
touched them they'd never make it back
alive venturing out of the mine in his
overalls Jerry had seen the shuffling
melted mass that had once been the
townsfolk he did his best to avoid it as
he went house to house making sure it
never saw him while he raided cupboards
and refrigerators but he could see it
and among the Blobs of bodies Blended
together he saw something that resembled
his daughter it turned his stomach not
just knowing but actually witnessing
what had happened to her and it was made
all the worse on the days that Carly
called out to him and Kyle while they
hid in the mine it was clearly her voice
but there was something wrong about it
perhaps knowing that she was a part of
the melted monstrosity made it easier to
resist her trying to coax them out into
the light it had almost been an entire
year of Life spent Underground when
Jerry and Kyle encountered their first
actual human beings since all the other
workers had left the mine the pair that
arrived were strange wearing protective
suits that covered them both head to toe
just like Jerry and Kyle had quickly
realized these two were aware that not
even the tiniest hint of the Sun's
unforgiving light could be allowed to
reach them the two approached Jerry and
Kyle seemingly coming in peace although
the Father and Son remained cautious of
the newcomers making sure they were deep
enough in the mind to avoid the sunlight
at the Stony entrance the pair of them
revealed their faces confirming they
were still fully human before
introducing themselves as researcher
worth and Sergeant Booker of the SCP
Foundation sitting down with Jerry worth
explained what had really happened he
had been working for an organization
that contained and studied anomalous
creatures and phenomena the foundation
Booker had been a member of a special
armed unit within the same establishment
or a mobile task force but now the SCP
Foundation itself had fallen with a
number of its own Personnel turned into
more of the amorphous fleshy creatures
in the sunlight we spent a lot of years
keeping all this from the public worth
admitted sounding guilty but implying
the choice was out of his hands but I
don't suppose there's any point in
Secrets anymore ah it's the sun you see
Mr Marks ah you can call me Jerry he
interrupted sorry Jerry worth corrected
himself but something happened to the
sun it changed decimated the entire
planet in barely any time at all I mean
all those people millions billions all
at once dear God worth took a moment as
the existential dread of it all once
again caught up with him it turned out
the biggest anomaly was right about
above us Booker continued for him she
sounded a lot more stoic even a little
coldly detached from it all
scp-001 that's what the foundation
called it is there a way to reverse it
or cure the people that the sunlight you
know changes Jerry asked thinking of
Carly you mean
scp-001-a no I'm sorry Jerry there's
nothing we can do the researcher said
failing to sound as recomposed as he
pretended to be your daughter is gone
but at least you still have your worth
paused looking around at the mine even
in the low light there was no sign of
Kyle Jerry turned to scan the area to
his horror his son had seemed to vanish
while they were talking instantly Panic
caused him to think that Kyle had
wandered out of the mine and into the
sunlight turning into part of what worth
had called
scp-001-a but the boy would have had to
walk past Jerry to start heading that
direction plus the father knew his son
was far too scared to go outside after
seeing what this had done to Carly
Booker had a tactical bag filled with
equipment flashlights spare batteries
even flares for whenever the power in
those ran out and both working and
living in the mine so long Jerry had
Maps knew certain routes through the
Deep network of tunnels almost by heart
between them the three had enough to
mount a search for the missing boy
keeping together they traversed away
from the first of several large Chambers
down into the dark depths of the mine ah
his father yelled his voice echoing
through the tunnel Kyle body it's dead
you there walking behind him researcher
worth and Sergeant Booker parroted the
calls assuring the missing boy that they
didn't mean him or Jerry any harm as the
trio walked deeper and deeper they began
to venture into a portion of the mine
that had hardly been used by the workers
it was darker than the areas for the
rump while those had rows of electric
lamps powered by long cables attached to
generators down here the only light came
from the flashlights the group carried
Carl come on Al Jerry called out first
time again this isn't the time to split
up we need to stick together come on son
I'm really worried here once again there
was no answer just then Jerry caught the
set of Booker and worth out of the
corner of his eye both of them knew a
lot about scp-001 and the mine worker
couldn't help the suspicion that added
to his perception of them after all Kyle
had never run off before now and Jerry
couldn't help but think while his
attention had been turned that the para
Foundation Personnel had taken his son
dad a voice suddenly called out Jerry's
head spun on a swivel at the sound of
Kyle calling for him Dad where are you
it echoed through the tunnel again
that's him Jerry exclaimed to the other
two which way did that come from
Straight Ahead it sounds like Booker
replied hold on worth interjected I
think you two should look at this the
beam from his flashlight was pointed at
the rocky floor of the tunnel something
was gleaming went against the stone a
large smear of red like something had
been dragged in the direction Kyle's
voice was coming from oh God he could be
hurt Jerry said urgently hurt might not
be the right word I'm afraid Jerry the
researcher said solemnly there's a lot
of blood here too much all the more
reason to go further and find where he's
calling from the father retorted angrily
that's if it is the kid that's actually
calling us Booker replied her and worth
exchanging a worry glance at each other
you two know something don't you Jerry
demanded does that thing from the
outside does it have my son too Dad
another voice called Jerry froze his
blood as cold as the mine tunnel who
stood in he hadn't heard that voice in
almost a year but recognized it
immediately it was Carly his daughter it
seemed impossible he knew she had been
merged into part of
scp-001-a when day broke but now she was
somehow calling out to Jerry her voice
sounded clearer like it had used to
before she changed and she wasn't trying
to lure her father out into the sunlight
either her for a moment it seemed to
Jerry like his daughter had somehow come
back dad were both over here Carly's
voice called again we need your help
Kyle's stuck who's that Booker whispered
that's Carly Jerry sniffed holding back
tears you said your daughter became a
part of
scp-001-a worth pointed out maybe she
got better the father asked hopefully I
hate to say it but that's definitely not
her Sergeant Booker replied we should
turn back now if there's an anomaly in
these tunnels that's not going to be
pretty for any of us she had it turning
to worth what Jerry out what do you mean
by that look buddy those aren't your
children the MTF agent said bluntly it
sounded like
scp-001-8 got them no no the the voices
are too clear worth replied I think
something else is in here before Jerry
could explode with anger at how
uninterested both Foundation Personnel
seemed at the fate of his children
another sound Was Heard footsteps
something shuffling close are patting
its feet on the stone there was a low
growl that filled the tunnel as whatever
it was came closer still dad the voice
of Carly repeated sounding only a few
feet away now where are you Dad Kyle's
voice immediately followed it behind
came the sound of Booker striking a
flare as it erupted into a plume of
light and heat she threw it down the
tunnel and there they were not Jerry's
children but instead a pair of
nightmarish creatures they backed away
from the flare slightly the light still
illuminated their blood red forms
walking on all fours like wolves the
creatures elongated heads were missing
any eyes just Jaws filled with rows of
sharp Red Fangs dad came Kyle's voice
again emanating from one of the monsters
it was mimicking Jerry's son both of his
kids even having seen
scp-001-a at a distance the father could
barely believe his eyes 939s Booker
yelled II her flare illuminated them run
she pulled the sidearm and opened fire
the bang of each shot ringing loudly
through the tunnel the pair of 939s
pounced at her while Jerry and worth
turned to run back the way they had come
as the creatures attacked The Echoes of
the gunfire were replaced with blood
curdling screams what the hell are those
things Jerry yelled in a panic scp-939
researcher worth painted too much to
explain they're pack hunters and they're
and they're vicious what about Kyle and
Carly I heard their voices that's what
those monsters do they mimic human
speech to draw us out wear their prey
there's no telling how long they've been
down here they might have retreated to
the mine to avoid the sun on the surface
worth yelled the sound of the scp-939 is
getting closer were catching up right on
Jerry and Worth's heels why would they
come down here for the mine worker
huffed slightly ahead of the researcher
given his slightly stronger physique to
escape the sunlight worth replied
scp-939
his sentence was overtaken by a scream
as one of the blood red creatures caught
worth by the ankle knocking him down and
pulling him back to be devoured Jerry
didn't look back he just kept running
back through the tunnel the sound of
scp-939 calling after him and Kyle and
Carly's voices made it even harder not
to stop and turn even just for a second
but he reminded himself that if he
stopped running then he couldn't lure
the creatures out of the mine and into
the sunlight it wasn't how he'd ever
wanted to go out but maybe that way
Jerry would see his kids again now go
and check out scp-001 can scp-049
finally cure when day breaks and scp-001
when day breaks
scp-682 for more horrifying when
Daybreak scenarios